going
good morning everybody we are going to
get
going uh we will start with the pledge
this morning
representative Guthrie was supposed to
be the one to do it but since I don't
see him representative Elward you will
please
representative representative clerk
McDonald would you please call the
role yes Mr chairman uh Vice chairman in
power present representative
Guthrie cler is present representative
lus here representative Yella pres
representative Kelly representative aood
here representative Brown here
representative
kahill here and representative stavis
here representative Tetro here
representative Sebert here and
representative Gilman here
representative major here representative
Gallagher here representative Hicks I'm
here representative Howland here
representative priest here
representative Frank
here and Mr chairman
here thank you very much uh a couple
housekeeping items before we get going
uh representative Sebert welcome to
Municipal and County she is sitting in
for representative uh trevan
today um I'll remind everybody
especially when we take votes uh on the
committee please uh turn on your mic so
everybody can hear it uh as of now next
Tuesday is the next time we will be
meeting as a committee of course we have
this house session tomorrow but next
Tuesday at new uh 9:30 I believe the
notice went out yesterday on that I'm
seeing head shaking so that's
that okay with that we will go ahead
this morning we're doing a bunch of
execs we'll go ahead and start on House
Bill 1040 relative to including interest
in the deated property tax
refund and with that I believe I have a
motion from representative Brown open
go Mr chairman I'd like to uh make a
motion to um interim study this
second uh representative gotth three
seconds representative uh Brown would
you like to speak on
that uh Mr chairman I just think that
based on the uh refund policy that it's
uh just not appropriate that this time
to do
that thank you representative I I'll
also just add in this uh was on request
of the the sponsor
himself so any other comments on this
before we move on
no seeing none we'll ask the clerk to
call a
rooll okay uh Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yes clerk votes
yes representative lales yes
representative
yella yes representative Kelly um
representative aood yes representative
Brown yes representative kahill yes
represent Davis yes uh represent
T yes representative
cber yes representative Gilman yes
representative majy yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
represent of Howland
yes represent priest yes representative
Frank yes and Mr chairman yes motion
passes 19 to
zero thank you Mr clerk uh unless there
is an objection this will go on the
consent calendar seeing
none and representative
Brown G to be the committee
report yes Mr chairman thank you okay
with that that Clos the executive
session on 1040 we'll go ahead and
now as soon as Mr clerk is ready open up
the executive session on House Bill 128
relative to voting for
municipal
bonds open that up said John
representative stavis you have a motion
thank you Mr chair I would like to move
itl on this bill I'd like to speak to my
motion thank you do we have a second on
that second I see all kinds of seconds
uh representative Tetro will be the
second on that one and representative
stavis you'd like to speak thank you
again Mr chair um the bonding process is
an existentially important process for
Citizens across the state uh frequently
often involving many many millions of
dollars the taxpayers will end up having
to pay back over a period of many years
um in order to reach a yes decision on
the passage of a bond it should require
a two-thirds majority and not a simple
majority because it is such a an
important matter thank you Mr chair
thank
you is there any further discussion on
lales yes um it's my understanding you
mentioned a
2third uh requirement
now it's it's my understanding that many
bonds excuse me only require 60%
um and the and I totally agree with you
but why why would
you make this interim study rather than
itl the motion the motion is itl oh it
is
itm you can answer if you'd like I
misspoke okay but the motion is itl
representative savus hold on one sec um
anybody who's not speaking please turn
off your microphones
because it degrades the system thank you
all right any further comments on the
itl
motion seeing none we'll ask the clerk
rooll okay itl on hb1 1218 Vice chairman
power yes represent Guthrie click votes
yes representative ases yes
representative Keller yes representative
Kelly representative
yes representative Brown yes
representative kahill yes representative
Davis yes representative Tetro yes
representative Sebert yes representative
Gilman yes representative Maori other
no representative
Gallagher uh yes representative Hicks
yes representative Howland yes
representative priest
yes representative Frack yes Mr chairman
yes uh motion pass is 18 to
one representative majori do you object
to it going on the consent calendar I do
not object Mr chair okay very good all
right um the chairman of the committee
will write the report on that one uh and
with that we will close the exact
128 Mr chair ju I sorry I there won't be
a Minority Report on that one the 18 to
one unless you unless you insist I
didn't anticipate one okay thank
one you're more than welcome to no
no okay
okay uh next up House Bill uh executive
session on House Bill 1297 relative to
authority of municipalities to enforce
ordinances relative to health and safety
we open the hearing on that I understand
representative Gallagher has a motion uh
yes I would like to move ought to pass
on HB 1297 and uh speak to my
motion is there a second on that
representative yala
seconds and you may speak to your
motion so um
HB uh so hb1
is uh bipart uh bipartisan legislation
basically um setting some guidelines for
um
Municipal R making
um so uh specifically for zoning
ordinances um it
basically um just says zoning
ordinances um should be for the
promotion of residents health and safety
um
so in other
words um I I um
basically if it's an ordinance that's
just about someone's aesthetic
preferences or whatever then that isn't
really a valid use for um Municipal
ordinance making um I basically just see
this as a codification
of how governments should be um
legislating anyways um you know it's
a um it's a princip all that sees it's
an expression from uh lots of political
philosophers I believe Prime sponsor
called it
uh ref referred to um lafayette's
principle for it um I was thinking more
of John Stewart Mills harm principle um
about
basically intervening in other people's
Affairs should only be to prevent harm
to others rather than harm to
themselves um
so yeah that's
um I yeah I basically just see this as a
pretty basic statement of principles and
think it would make sense to
pass thank
you representative uh
priest thank you Mr chairman for taking
my question my comment I will be voting
against hb12 97 because it is in direct
conflict um with our existing statutes
on chapter
674 and it spells out the purposes of
zoning which is to lessen congestion in
streets and to secure safety and to
promote health and general welfare so we
already have this in our books for the
zoning and
um and that's basically it thank
you representative
lales I
um will
Echo representative
priest's
remarks and I think that this
legislation although well-meaning has
far-reaching
consequences that are totally
unintended and so I will vot be voting
no on this
thank you representative representative
howand thank you um so in my real
problem of course is Roman numeral 2 so
if it really is about safety then you
wouldn't carve out your commercial zones
your family structures or five or more
units that that are Exempted from this
what this is really doing is it's
tackling duplexes and forp plexes and it
takes away the municipalities ability to
regulate it which I don't think is a
really good idea so I I I'll support the
itl
thank you
representative
yala thank you I plan on voting in
support of this and um I think that the
um consequences are intended and I wish
that it went further and did not carve
out those those uh things uh
representative Howen uh stated but going
one step is better than no steps so I
will be voting in support represent
majority
thank you Mr chairman I I'll be um
voting against the ought to pass um but
for more technical reasons uh when we
had the hearing we even heard from the
prime sponsor that there were technical
issues with the bill that needed to be
corrected I don't see an amendment uh I
think those those fixes are more than
just uh uh ministerial or administrative
the wrong uh the wrong section of RSA is
cited uh language about which body is
responsible is is incorrect
um and I think those changes uh if this
bill were to go forward this is more
than just the other body fixing it or a
floor Amendment so for all the reasons
that I hear from my friends uh opposed
uh I I will be also voting against the
ought to pass thank you thank you
representative further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
to call a role on the motion of a to
pass okay OTP HB
1297 Vice chairman power no
representative Guthrie no clerk votes no
representative Rosales
no representative K
yes representative Kelly representative
Ood no representative Brown no
Representative kahill no Representative
stavis no representative
Tetro
no representative
uh representative
Gilman no Representative maor no
representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks no
representative Howland no representative
Priest No representative Frank no and Mr
chairman
no motion fails uh
16-3 thank you Mr clerk uh represent
Senator PRI yes I would like to make a
motion to
itl hb1
1297 I'll second the
motion okay uh stand by one second so
representative
priest and representative Cahill is the
second thank you uh would you like to
speak to that or are you all set I'm all
set thank you thank you further comments
questions
when the clerk is ready we'll take the
vote on the motion of
itl by representative priest okay itl
1297 uh Vice chairman of power yes
represent Guthrie cliar votes yes
representative Silas yes representative
Kella
no Kelly awood yes representative Brown
yes representative
kahill yes representative stavis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
CIT no representative Gilman
yes representative Jory yes
representative Gallagher
no representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Frank yes and Mr chairman yes motion
passes 16 to three thank you uh any
objections to it going on consent I see
an objection representative
Gallagher um the chairman will be
writing the majority report on the
itl uh will somebody be
writing somebody over there I I believe
be uh
okay that's fine representative yella
Report okay with that closes the
moving right along when the clerk is
ready we will go ahead and open up an
executive session on HB
1362 relative to authorizing
municipalities to stabilize rent
increases in rental
housing I believe believe representative
Gallagher has a motion again yeah I'd
like to move to pass on this and speak
to my
second hearing no second we'll open it
up to further second I'll second can I
second I wasn't sure if I
could
okay sry you may just um
little prompter next time
OTP representative Gallagher would like
to speak to your
motion yeah so
um I am moving opop pass on HB
1362 um relative to authorizing
municipalities to stabilize rent
increases in rental housing um so this
is enabling legislation um as we heard
from the municipal Association
um
it just gives the municipality something
um an extra tool to try if they'd like
to um and um we've debated whether or
not um rent stabilization is different
from rent control or not I'd argue that
it is in fact different due to the fact
that um
normally
um so normally bills aren't allowed in
the second year of a term if they were
the same thing as bill from the first
year of the term
um and since the we had a rent control
bill in the first year of the term and
then had this or now having this bill in
the second year of the term that to me
sounds like the speaker has ruled that
so yeah we rent rents have been going up
a lot lately
um a recent study found
that um half of renters Nationwide were
spending more than 30% of their income
on rent in
20122 um that's a lot
um and so uh one one of the objections
we heard was um instead of trying rent
control we should be or rent
stabilization we should be um doing
these
other zoning reforms instead um
and well I I I don't think a single one
of
the witnesses saying we should do those
instead
satisfactory answered my question of why
not do both I mean the bill we just
heard was one of or the Bill we just
exec the one about zoning regulations
was pres one of the ones that they
presumably would have supported um in
terms of loosening zoning so um and I
support that one as well so um I think
that yeah it this this would be a bill
to um be in the benefit of the health
and safety of
its residence um and is exactly the sort
of kind of thing we should be passing um
bill representative
priest thank you Mr chairman I will be
opposing uh HB
1362 uh for numerous reasons um one uh I
think if you wanted to provide more
affordable housing you provide
incentives for the developer in the
zoning code and that is already allowed
and so there are some creative ways to
increase affordable housing in our
communities um second I have SE I have
lived in areas where there has been rent
stabilization uh or rent control
whatever you want to call it um and all
you see are landlords pulling out of
their responsibility for the upkeep of
their housing because they cannot afford
to make the improvements and to maintain
them and keep the rents below market
rate so I've seen this and what you get
is a supply of housing that are
dilapidated and and probably
slums so that is why I'm opposing this
Bill thank representative representative
Hicks thank you Mr chairman I also will
be opposing this bill um I think when
we're
talking about this issue I think there's
a an understanding that landlords are
making a lot of money off their renters
um I'm not a landlord but I know many
who are and I the people I know are not
making a lot of money off the renters
they are working with them they're
trying to keep them in their housing um
so I think this is well intention but I
don't think there's a real understanding
understanding about renters and
landlords and I don't think there's a
real understanding about um the
consequences of this I think those are
either being ignored or they're not
being considered enough so I'll be
opposing
it representative
Holland thank you um so I think my first
problem is where you're doing the
calculation of the allowable rent
increase uh that it's going to be an
administrative nightmare actually when
you have to go to every single landlord
and calculate what their billing
Building looks like it should be tied to
more of a standard which is Workforce
housing that takes uh 60% of area median
income and so you'd have a regular
standard that you can work for uh the
other thing is that uh to to uh speak to
uh representative priest also spoke to
it was the uh the incentives so right
now uh using RSA 79 e4c the Housing
Opportunity Zone uh we're carving out
30% of the the developers by is agreeing
with us and says yes I'll go forward
I'll give you 30% of that development is
going to be in in that defin thing I
just said Workforce housing and it goes
forward I think communities have the
ability we are currently to work around
with your density bonuses you use your
density bonus so that it makes the
project workable but when we do that in
the towns uh negotiation we're
negotiating how much of that project
actually is Workforce housing I think
that's the way to attack it not this way
so I I would recommend itl on this
represent
stavis thank you Mr chair I will also be
opposing this bill for all of the
reasons stated by my
colleagues um at the other end of the
table but also because of um the risk of
the the unintended consequences should
it pass I'm thinking of towns that are
adjacent to one another one passes an
ordinance and the other doesn't all the
developers flock to the one that doesn't
and all the developers flee the ones
that do and what do does that do to the
structures and the governance and the
Democratic process of those towns that
have passed that ordinance and have
suddenly seen all of their potential
developers leave the area to go to
another town that does not have this
ordinance I also think that it it
basically renders moot all of the
creative and inclusionary Zoning efforts
that have already taken place that have
already been mentioned 78e Workforce
housing density
bonuses um in the city of Lebanon the
city is buying Parcels of land
specifically to build Workforce housing
and cottage zoned areas and if this were
to pass and the city adopted such an
ordinance
the the impulse to do these creative
things would would vanish and I really
worry about that unintended
consequence thank you representative
further comments uh representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair um one of my
concerns with this bill is just the uh
amount of administration that it will
take um I the number of rentable
properties in my town is quite numerous
and this is going to involve every
landlord proving that they uh have uh
reason to either raise well to raise
their rents to meet their needs as far
as the upkeep um and it says any you
know any governing body Etc U but you
know Board of selectman isn't going to
go through this process uh they're going
to have to establish a um a body to do
it it's going to take more than one
person so that's why I'm opposed to this
bill major thank you Mr chairman um I
say unfortunately I'm going to be um
opposing the ought to pass
I rents spikes and rents are are real
and and they are terribly unfortunate
and they they do have a a major effect
on lots of people in our state we need
to figure something out um just last
night the town of Northampton in a plany
board meeting was discussing our effort
we are about to engage on to reverse
engineer through a root cause analysis
why why is our real estate so expensive
and how can we make things more
affordable and even just scratching the
surface we realize that that this kind
of effort to stabilize rent is is so far
down the list of how we can make things
more affordable we we this is important
but it it will only work in the short
term and many many studies across the
country have proven that this will have
a short-term benefit like in a year but
long-term detrimental impacts so I
cannot find a reason to support the
legislation thank
you
sales I feel that this bill is a rather
pristine
example of well-meaning people trying to
insert the government into something
that should be the privy of
private
Enterprise the only way now what what we
have now in our housing crisis is that
we have a lot and this is not the only
reason but we have a lot of people
coming from other states with piles of
cash who are coming into New Hampshire
and paying whatever the market will will
bear which is pushing out a lot of of
our
longterm New Hampshire citizens
so this this is very well-meaning
but over the long period of
time any attempt at rent control or rent
stabilization has proven itself over and
over and
representative for the
kale um you know I I greatly appreciate
everybody on this committee and I we do
have a
problem that we need to solve in in New
Hampshire with with our housing cost C
that this bill just doesn't do it and I
think to Echo my colleague sentiments
there's other ways to do that there's
other ways to do that and one of them is
like bringing down energy costs and
things like that there's there's ways
that you can bring down building costs
there's ways that we can work together
to solve this problem so I I I will be
not supporting theat to pass motion on
this
B seeing no further comments we ask the
clerk to call a role on the motion of
OTP aop pass
okay uh 1362 OTP uh Vice chairman of
power no representa Guffy no cck votes
no Representative lilus no
representative Kella
no Representative awood no
representative Brown no Representative
kahill no Representative stavis no
representative Tetro no representative
cber
yes representative Gilman no
Representative majori no representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks no
representative Howland no representative
priest no uh represent Frack
no and Mr chairman uh
no motion fails uh 2 to
17 representative uh k do you have a
motion on this thank you Mr chair I move
uh itl on House Bill
1362 I'll second thank you U
representative uh I'm gonna put
representative stavis on if you don't
mind representative stavis
seconds and I'm assuming representative
kill you do not need to speak any
further on this or do you uh no sir I
think we've addressed it thank you
forther
comments represent representative Sebert
could you click that microphone off for
you thank you okay we'll ask the clerk
to call the rooll on the motion of
V okay itl 1362 Vice chairman in power
yes represent Guthrie collect votes yes
representative Salis yes uh
representative
Keller yes representative aood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kahill yes representative stavis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
CIT
no representative Gilman yes
representative majori yes representative
Gallagher no representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
FR yes and Mr chairman yes motion pass
of
17-2 is there any objections to it going
on the
consent seeing none it'll go on the
consent
calendar um does anybody intend to write
a Minority Report on this I'm seeing
nobody uh the chairman will write the
committee report on the itail motion on
this one
also okay that closes the exact session
on
okay next we will open up an executive
session on
hb152 relative to the format of
Excavating and dredging permit
applications I understand representative
Brown has an amendment he would like to
introduce thank you Mr chairman as
discussed at the initial hearing we do
have a uh amendment to propos 202
24-35 4 which I believe everybody has
basically what this hold on we need a
somebody to Second sorry I believe that
I'll will second the motion
representative kahill seconds the
amendment now representative Brown would
you like to speak to your Amendment I'm
a little anxious as always at any rate
uh so what this amendment does is
simplify the process for for um these
types of permits which allows the
townships to reduce their their storage
of documents and allows the uh quicker
and more efficient utilization of these
documents including electronic documents
for people to review and to retain and
to potentially uh provide to uh people
who have inquiries about the details of
this uh it's in front of you I
appreciate your support of this
amendment thank you representative other
there further
comments I see none we'll ask the clerk
to call a rooll when he's ready on the
the
amendment Amendment uh 2024
H okay adopt the amendment uh 0354 each
uh Vice chairman power
yes representative Guthrie collect votes
yes representative lales yes
representative yella yes representative
Kelly representative awood yes
representative Brown yes representative
kahill yes representative stavis yes
represent T yes representative
Sebert yes representative Gilman yes
representative Maori yes representative
Gallagher
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes representative
Fran yes and uh Mr
zero okay 19 to zero on the amendment
now we'll move on to HP 1052 as amended
do I hear a motion on that
representative Brown yes I'd like to
make the uh motion to
otpa House Bill 1052 as amended thank
you do we have a second representative K
second motion pres kahill seconds
further
discussion seeing none uh represent
gallager um
so um yeah I I'm going to be supporting
this um but I'd just like to um repeat a
point I made from the hearing just for
the record um in case any future
interpreters are looking back to the
intent behind the law um so I'm voting
uh I'm voting for this with the
understanding that the
other um the other data formats allowed
uh are in compliance with RSA 21
r10 uh Roman 1 and um yeah having
received a insurance is that that is in
fact the intent that they' be in
compliance with that then um yeah I I um
think that's enough to ask why me and
priest there we go uh thank you Mr
chairman um I will be
supporting um the oop pass as amended
house bill
81052 I think it's long overdue and it
does simplify the process and anything
that can bring efficiency in I'm all for
thank you excellent points
representative further comments seeing
none when the rep um clerk is ready we
call a
roll okay uh 1052 ought the pastors
amended Vice chairman power yes
representative Guthrie yes clict votes
yes
representative lales yes representative
yella yes representative orward yes
representative Brown yes representative
kill yes representative Davis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
cber yes representative Gilman yes
representative majori yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes represent Fran
yes and Mr chairman yes uh motion passes
19 to
zero thank you Mr clerk without
objection um it will go on to the
consent
calendar seeing no
objections it will go on consent
representative Brown will be the
committee report author thank you Mr
chairman thank you
okay with that we close the exec session
okay as the clerk finishes preparing for
this one we will go ahead and open up
the exec session on HB
1055 relative to property tax exemption
for
charitable
organizations and I
believe representative McDonald has a
motion OTP on uh n55
thank you do we have a second
second okay representative guthy seconds
that
motion and Mr clerk would you like to
speak to your yeah I'll just say a
couple of words uh it's a common sense
and reasonable bill that will help the
smaller uh nonprofits and their
communities uh to better address the
issues related to becoming uh getting
the tax exemption on their uh property
you further com representative
power thank you Mr chair I support this
this bill the motion ought to pass and I
would also like to point out that the
the language the bolded italicized
language in the bill is the same exact
language that appears in
7223 DC the annual list as well as
another section of Statute 7237 Dasa
exemption for improvements to assist
persons with disabilities
so therefore um this bill brings this
particular section of Statute in line
two thank you representative
yella thank you I will be voting in
opposition to this uh bill I don't think
that that uh Charities need to have the
same
uh exception ability that disabled
people have and I think that that's uh
spir like just irrelevant um trying to
make it uh in Conformity with that I
think that uh they should just follow
the law as it is and if they don't then
accept the penalties just like everyone
else representative Guth thank you Mr
chair my reason for
seconding uh the motion was mainly
because things
happen and they happen to different
groups of people and I think that this
since it says the officials
May uh receive the application there
there's some options there on the part
of the board of Selectmen so I feel
comfortable with this as I say things
happen and we ought to can take that
into consideration thank you thank you
Mr
comments seeing none I will make one on
this
I I kind of straddle the fence on this
one myself representative yella made
some uh good points and the point that
representative Guthrie just made to the
uh to the point of the word may I I
personally don't like the word may I
think that should be it should be either
a
shall or nothing um when you when you
use the word may especially in these
senses and I know it's in other places
in the rsas when you use the word may
you're opening up to potential
political U implications or subjective
political moves I will support it but I
just want that on the record further
comments seeing none we'll ask the clerk
to call okay uh HB 1055 OTP Vice
chairman power yes representative
Guthrie yes click votes yes
representative silus yes represent Jella
no Representative aood
no representative Brown yes
representative
kahill yes representative stavis yes
representative Tetro yes representative
cert
yes uh representative Gilman yes
representative major yes representative
Gallagher yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative priest yes and
representative frat
yes uh Mr chairman
yes uh motion passes
17-2 thank you Mr clerk is there an
objection to this going on consent
I see
none uh
representative McDonald I assume you
will be the committee report author yes
Mr thank
you okay with that we'll close the
executive on
1055 we are done very early so before
you
leave we'll see everybody back here at 1
but if you are writing a committee
report on one of these bills if you have
the ability and opportunity to do it we
have couple hours if we can get that in
now we can get this on uh on the
calendar for tomorrow and these would be
in the pipeline for next Thursday's
house session so if you could please do
that now that would be much
one
folks
actually I guess we could go by that
one's all right well it's close enough
uh welcome back everybody Welcome to
everybody in the audience today we're
going to open up the house uh hearing on
HB 1001 relative to exempting the land
and buildings of masonic lodges and
associations from property taxations I
see the prime sponsor is here
uh he filled out his pink card as
Representatives Packard but I think uh
floor thank you Mr
chairman it's been a crazy
morning um and uh members of the
committee um you know my name is Sher
Packard and I represent Rockingham
district 16 town of
Londoner and uh I'm also as I think
everybody knows speaker of the house and
I've been a uh Freemason since
2009 I'm here today to introduce House
Bill
101 to this committee because the Masons
in New
Hampshire are now in a place that the
Grange was back in
1983 when House Bill 67
passed and added them to RS a 72 Co and
23 list of
exemptions The Grange was added to the
exempting list because their numbers
were
diminishing despite their benefit to
society in 1983 when house bille 67
passed New Hampshire Masons numbered
over
13,000 unfortunately 40 years later
we're just over
3700 right now and our numbers on
fortunately decline
annually by adding the grains through
the exemption list 40 years ago we save
the organization from probably
ruination and I'm hopeful we can do the
same thing for Granite State
Masons uh this bill exempts lodges in
towns that have them and I think there's
around 55 56 towns that have them right
now and uh just U my logic in
Candia we uh old annual fundraisers for
the food pantry we allow the building to
be used for Scouts Town committees
nonprofits and much more we allow this
free of charge because up until this
year we were not charged a uh property
tax and so we were able to return all
our stuff all that to the town Plus
money
unfortunately uh over the last few years
several lodges have had
to literally close or combine with
another
Lodge and um I just want to put a side
note in here that um I've also been a
member of the legendary liance club for
years and um we were one of the few
places
Lions Clubs in the state that had our
own
building and unfortunately we had to
give that building up because it was a
200 year old building and we couldn't
afford to do our fundraising and return
money to the town like we wanted to and
uh keep the building up at the same
time and I want to make it perfectly
clear here
that there's a small group of lodges in
the state that actually have some
property rentals where they rent out to
certain businesses they would not be
exempt under this they would still have
to continue to
uh I think I'll end it at that
point
um I did talked to people from the
municipal
Association a while back and they asked
if we could possibly include something
that might take a look at the whole
thing about exemptions for different
properties and Mr chairman I would maybe
suggest that if you without having to
put it into legislation and make another
commission which you know I
hate uh uh maybe you could have a
subcommittee of this committee you know
formed to take a look at that at some
point you know moving forward
and come back and uh you know give us an
find and uh also I'd like to point out
that this is a bipartisan piece of
legislation and uh I want to thank the
Democratic leader who is not Amon but
comes from Manchester and knows the
benefit that that Lodge gives the uh
city of Manchester my old Hometown and
with with that I will try and take any
questions but we have uh a number of uh
people here that are the Grand Master
and stuff that will probably do a much
better job of uh telling you where we're
at right now than than I could probably
do it thank you Mr Speaker um what I
will suggest is the speaker's itinerary
I'm certain is probably pretty busy um
if we can hold questions for other
presenters that might be um better but
uh represent savis if you have one go
ahead thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question Mr Speaker um how
would the Masonic lodges that do rent
out their properties know that they were
not exempt under this legisl how would
they know well I I I think the I think
there's five or six that do rent out
properties and obviously they'd be
informed that they didn't qualify for
the
exemption I know nashwa I think nashwa
is one of the towns that has some rental
property and there's a couple others but
uh there's only about half a dozen of
them that actually I think and I could
be corrected by the grandm but there's
only I think about six of them that
actually have some rental property they
own a building and rent part of it out
for
something but obviously they would
qualify further questions for the
speaker seeing none thank you m speaker
for your testimon thank you
Mr okay next up we will call
Representative
Wier thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee representative Ken
Wier Rockingham 14 Kingston and East
Kingston as a co-sponsor of hb1001 I
would like to give you some reasons to
support this bill as you would expect
ECT I am a Mason and have been for 39
years I take it to heart that one of our
claims is that we make good men better
we have as an association a long history
we were derived from the guilds that
constructed the European Cathedrals that
were built hundreds of years ago and are
still standing The Guild had a few steps
that a member would progress through
Entered Apprentice fellowcraft then
Master Mason we've copied that
progression in the similar lessons one
must learn to progress we're careful who
we choose to enter the fraternity and
many of the members are involved in each
person's progress being good citizen one
of our requirements thus we are involved
in our communities our buildings are
frequently used by youth groups as well
as other community organizations our
parking lots are open to our neighbors
and others when we are not meeting the
Masons also created and sponsored other
groups for young women rainbow girls for
young men dlay for couples Eastern Star
and the Grange when these groups
obtained their buildings the Masons
worked to get those buildings property
tax exemptions and you will find those
exemptions already in law but being good
citizens I am sure that the Masons would
have said we're proud to pay our share
to support our community that was a
different time we had far more members
and property taxes were much lower than
today many of our lodges are over 100
years old and the maintenance costs
likely up likely to use up most of the
dues we pay we still maintain the
charitable giving that The Lodges always
supported such as local food pantries
youth organizations members relief or
members relief scholarships veterans
organizations and others in the last
five years the Masons collectively
contributed
$500,000 to their local communities I
was successful in my town of Kingston in
gaining tax exemption at town meeting in
1992 some other lodges have as well but
we have heard many unsuccessful attempts
since we're all non profit charitable
organizations we think this tax
exemption should be Statewide as those
groups Rec created that I earlier
mentioned are as Veterans as our
veterans organizations we more than make
up for any burden that we may impose on
the communities where we live and we
believe that we are improving some of
that community's members thank you I'd
questions representative
Gallagher um so I'm just noticing in in
the bill textt so um in the first
section it lists um every religious
educational and charitable
organization um or Grange um and before
listing Masonic l or Masonic Association
so why would why aren't the Masons
already considered as fitting under one
of those existing
categories as I said I believe that you
know as part of ever um wish to be
better citizens and support of our
community probably the Mason said you
know please help these other groups that
are struggling but we are willing to pay
our taxes to support the community as
part of being good citizens however as
was mentioned we had far more members
than when that was likely said and we
also did not have the the heavy property
tax burden the property tax burdens have
have accelerated far ahead of inflation
so that the
much less affordable now as we all know
ago representative
lales yes thanks for taking my question
um can anybody join the
Masons no we go through a selective
process and and you should get a few
Masons to sign your your uh application
and we don't we look at people to see
they're standing in the community what
their background is what they've done in
their lives and and not everyone is
accepted we also do a background
investigation followup Mr chairman
follow up I I happen to be a student of
history and I know that the Masons have
a long history in this country and there
were times in the history of the United
States where Catholics were prohibited
from joining the
Masons um I know that we have various
organizations that discriminate based
upon uh race gender and so forth I'm
just I I really don't know much about
the Masons but if you could enlighten me
about uh the openness of membership the
only reason I'm saying this is I'm
struggling in my mind as to why anybody
would object to what you're asking for
and I'm I'm just trying to see if
there's anything that we can get out
ahead of it well as I said
the the ethos has evolved over the
decades we have Catholic Masons we have
we have black Masons we have Hispanics
and so on and at one time one of my
friends that was in both the Knights of
columb and the Mason said at one time
because the Mason said you must keep the
secrets that we give you that the
Catholics felt they couldn't join
because they couldn't keep secrets from
their priest but that was kind of a
self-imposed thing but and that was one
told to me by a Catholic which I'm not
but that was one of the things that
supposedly kept them out at the time
because oh you can't have secrets away
from your priest that was what they
believed and that was what some of them
chose to believe thank you
representative Elwood thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question going back to uh my colleague
question about uh use of the word
charitable organization in the first uh
line do you know how the Masons are
organized for IRS purposes uh C3 501c3
C4 there's a specific one for Mason 501
C10 followup Mr
chairman followup and are you um do you
accept public
donations we
have thank you very much thank
you representative Gilman thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my question um I I am not going
to uh uh take an action here but I
wanted your opinion um
here we're discussing Masonic lodges and
associations becoming tax exempt but
there are uh other frat fraternal
organizations and not I don't know the
word for women but like the Daughters of
the American Revolution they don't
necessarily own property but I know the
Odd Fellow do and they're still active
so my opinion is should we get somebody
in this committee perhaps who is a uh
Mason or from another fraternal would
you object to that change of not taking
the Masons out and just making it a
fraternal orders I would not
object I'll work on
you representative Brown representative
Elwood could you turn your mic off
please thank you repres Brian thank you
Mr Speaker um as a co-sponsor um I guess
my question is do you feel the reason
why you need this bill is primarily
because of the historical precedent that
you folks put on yourselves by not
taking the exemption early
you
representative stavis did you still have
a question I do
um Freemasons are specifically mentioned
in RSA
2921 the volunt associations act um and
all organizations in that act are exempt
from federal
taxes as it says in the
RSA is it true that if you're exe an
organization exempt from federal taxes
that does not necessarily exempt you
from state taxes I'm I'm just asking yes
case represent of
power
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question could you please
explain um in lines three and four it
states Masonic Lodge or Masonic
Association what is the distinction
between the two and what exactly are
each how are they different thank you it
is is just a choice that the
organization chooses our constitution
says you should have a Building
Association apart from the Masonic
Association for a brief period
my my Lodge did not have a build
Building Association because we we sold
the building then we bought it back and
when we bought it back we didn't form a
Building Association so we were just the
Masonic Lodge so it was it's still the
same building in various times it has
different way of incorporating and
sometimes I believe the encouragement
from the Grand Lodge is that you should
have a Building Association but there
are a few that do
not
representative uh kill thank you Mr
chair thank thank you representative for
taking my question um you guys stated
there was 55 to 56 towns um or buildings
um do we do we have an idea of how much
tax revenue that that that currently is
for those
properties well one I remember that I
was once in a position where I went
around and visited The Lodges within my
district was uh Portsmouth has a very
big building and it has two lodges that
meet there and they have a big parking
lot and at one point the um the city
made a deal with them we'll pay you
$20,000 to use your parking lot part of
the time when you're not needing it I
said that sounds good what are you
paying taxes the taxes were up to
40,000 and you know my taxes in Kingston
would probably likely be around 8 or
9,000 ,000 did did we not have an
exemption that's almost what we pay
every year and for all our needs so um
and and some of the some of the U lodges
that have a part of the building rented
out
full-time uh have a deal with some of
the cities of towns that they are exempt
in the portion of the building that is
just strictly used by the Masons but pay
taxes on the part that is rented out so
you know that's there there's different
things in different towns but the taxes
are depends on where you are and later
on I went to uh have a meeting with the
one in Hampton and Hampton was on a road
that had been a dead end and they said
the town wants to cut across our
property to get to the the end of that
Dead End Road and make it available to
get to their town yard where they keep
some things and they want to know how
much we want to to use that right away
and I said don't make the mistake
Portsmouth made at one point Portsmouth
probably could have said we'll let you
use the parking lot in exchange for the
property taxes so that's what Hampton
did at my advice will let you use the
right away for property exemption so the
two things equal probably when they
first started out with uh renting out
the parking lot in in Portsmouth it was
about equal to what they paid INX taxes
but the taxes go up and the rental
doesn't so there's various things we can
do but that has to be one of the things
you have to take care and in doing so
you kind of come out
even further questions for
representative
Wier seeing none thank you very much for
your testimon thank
you and uh we have a uh a very active
Mason and a past uh Speaker of the House
George Roberts who's has list is on your
list to be called he says he'd like to
come last so he doesn't uh repeat a lot
of the things that are said if you would
honor that thank you sounds good next up
I show uh Daniel is it Hutchins or Hutch
kiss
Mr
thank you again Mr chairman for allowing
me to speak today distinguished house
committee
members I appear before you today with
the current honor and privilege of
serving the Freemasons of new Hamp
Hampshire as grandm and I certainly
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to you today to talk about Freemasonry
here in New
Hampshire as I noted my name is Dan
hoskis and I'm a lifelong New Hampshire
resident having grown up in gwn
attending gtown Public
Schools after graduating from Gastown
High School I studied at and graduated
from New Hampshire college now Southern
New Hampshire University in
Manchester I currently reside in wear
with my wife of 36 Year's April also a
lifelong New Hampshire resident having
raised our two daughters in our
beautiful
state Freemasonry is an organization
that has been around for hundreds of
years and while it has evolved over time
its primary teachings of Brotherly Love
relief and Truth have remained
constant as Freemasons we are taught
that by the exercise of Brotherly Love
we are all part of one family that
belief of the distressed is a duty
incumbent upon all and that truth is the
foundation of every
virtue these virtues are encompassed in
our Declaration of masonic principles
which were developed hundreds of years
ago the Grand Lodge of New Hampshire was
founded in
1789 these principles date back to the
early
1800s and the verbiage that is going to
follow is certainly vocabul that we
don't necessarily use in today's
world Freemasonry is a charitable
benevolent an educational Society its
principles are proclaimed as widely as
men will hear its only secrets are in
its methods of recognition and of
symbolic
instruction it is charitable in that it
is not organized for profit and none of
its income enures to the benefit of any
IND individual but all is devoted to the
promotion of the welfare and happiness
of
mankind it is benevolent in that it
teaches and exemplifies altruism as a
duty it is educational in that it
teaches by prescribed ceremonials a
system of morality and
Brotherhood through the Improvement and
strengthening of the character of the
individual man free aary seeks to
improve the
community thus it impresses upon its
members the principles of personal
righteousness and personal
responsibility enlightens them as to
those things which make for human
Weare and inspires them with a feeling
of Charity and Good Will toward all
mankind which will move them to
translate principle and conviction into
action
that action is evident in the charitable
Endeavors Masons provide in and for our
communities both in monetary and
monetary and non-monetary
ways I'm sure many of you have heard of
the shiners and are aware of the
benevolence provided by the Shriners
hospitals for
children did you know that all Shriners
are also
Masons the Shriners of New Hampshire
contribute hundreds of thousands of
dollars to the three Shriner Hospital
facilities in the region specifically to
the Shriner hospitals in Boston
Massachusetts Springfield Massachusetts
and Montreal
Canada the Scottish wri Masons of New
Hampshire support many Charities but
more specifically two dyslexia centers
which are located in Nashua and
Rochester during The Last 5 Years alone
the Scottish wght Masons have provided
over a million and a half dollars of
monetary support for these two centers
that have served 195
students those Services which are often
not available in our Public Schools help
those students to overcome the learning
challenges presented by their dyslexia
diagnosis there are currently 55 Masonic
lodges in New Hampshire spread
throughout the state in our various
cities and
towns and Over The Last 5 Years alone
the Masons of these local Masonic lodges
have donated more than a half half a
million dollars to support local
charitable
organizations and provided more than
$250,000 in educational assistant grants
to deserving students from local schools
to help further their educational
goals in addition to these Financial
donations our local Masonic lodges open
their doors weekly to our Masonic youth
groups the order of deay for young men
and the Order of rainbow for girls to
Boy Scout and Girl Scout Troops to town
committees to food pantries to church
groups to the American Red Cross to AARP
and many other organizations allowing
use of the dining hall and other
building facilities free of charge or at
a very minimal
cost further the Masons of New Hampshire
are active members of their communities
serving their local churches serving on
local nonprofit boards volunteering as
Scout leaders volunteering as coaches of
local sports teams serving as EMTs and
firefighters these are only a few of the
local organizations to which the Masons
of New Hampshire dedicate their
time the Masons of New Hampshire
recognize that we are members of our
local communities and we understand the
importance of contributing to our
communities both financially and by
volunteering Our Time arm Masonic lodes
and the Masons who comprise them are
important members of our community and
have developed relationships with local
officials and the citizenry of our
cities and
towns those relationships have included
abatements from property taxes as local
Town governments acknowledg the
community support provided by the
Masons unfortunately
recently and recent decisions
implementing payment of full taxes by
Masonic lodges have negatively impacted
our lodges finances and our ability to
continue the financial support we
currently provide to local
organizations in closing I would
respectfully request that you consider
all of this information during your
during your deliberations of house bill
one1 as the passage of this bill will
allow the Masons of New Hampshire to
continue and perhaps even enhance the
contributions to benefit our communities
and the citizens of New
Hampshire I thank you again for the
opportunity to speak to you today and my
sincere hope is that I have been able to
shed some light on who the Masons of New
Hampshire are and the contributions we
make to our
communities I'm happy to take any
questions thank you for Testimony do I
see any questions representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question thank you so I
understand that um a previous speaker
said that the um Masonic lodges and
Masonic
associations they are um they fall under
the
501c I think he said 10 yeah because
they operate under a lodge system cor
whereas Section 8 is just a fraternal
organization so my understanding is um
domestic fernal societies fall under the
501 C10 section of the Internal Revenue
code the building associations that we
referenced fall under Section 501
C2 and those associations are
specifically designed basically as title
holding companies to hold buildings for
the rent of other nonprofit
organizations within the 501
section so that was just my lead in okay
but my question is I'm trying to I
wanted to establish that but because
there's another piece to this it's it's
nonprofit and charitable organization so
I'm trying to understand that under the
IRS code charitable organization comes
under
501c3 correct so is can we are all
Masonic lodges and build Masonic
building associations they also
organized under that
501c3 to make them charitable
organizations how do we know what's a
charitable organization in the state of
New Hampshire so domestic fraternal
societies like the Masons and other
fraternal organizations under that IRS
statute are specifically 501 C10 501c3
organizations are those normal Charities
that when you contribute to you were
able to deduct those contributions on
your income tax return and only 501c3
Charities but there are many other
nonprofit organizations within that 501
section and Masons fall under the 501
C10 specifically but as I noted in my
Declaration of masonic principles we are
charitable in that we do give back to
our
question represent FR thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question in your
testimony um you indicated that there
are some subgroups to Masons
specifically Shriner
uh Scottish rights and perhaps there are
other subgroups my question is it your
hb1001 that these
subgroups and the ones that you
mentioned and perhaps other ones also be
included as exempt all of those other
additional Masonic members of our family
meet in the buildings and the Masonic
lodges that are covered under the
proposed statute
so so followup followup go ahead so
those subgroups do not own real property
uh some may but again if they do own
property that is is rented out to
commercial space then they would be not
they would not be subject to this
particular
provision thank you thank you
Elward thank you Mr chairman thank you
for your testimony today so yes I'm I'm
kind of um looking at line
19 where it states if such property is
rented for business purposes the real
exempt correct me if I'm wrong were you
talking about a parking lot that is
sometimes used by a for a commercial
reason for
example would be a business
purpose you know that that's a very
interesting question I mean that that
particular portion of that statute was
already within there um we my
understanding is that the Masonic lodges
and associations were added up above uh
so my understanding of that particular
provision is that if there's any
commercial rental space that is provided
by these buildings or within these
buildings that they would not be exempt
under this particular
provision and representative wer I
believe did indicate that there are
probably five or six
Masonic lodges that would fall
specifically under that statute and they
are aware that they would not follow
under that
statute go ahead thank you so if the
property is rented out part-time for
business
calculated it's a good question I'm not
sure I have the ability to answer that
question based upon how the statute is
thank you you
questions seeing none I have two very
quick ones um on your last page of your
testimony You'
mentioned relationships have included
abatements from property
taxes uh so I'm assuming in the past
uh you've been able to get reductions or
elimination of property taxes and then
the next line it says unfortunately
recent decisions implementing payment of
full property tax could you explain what
those recent decisions
yeah I again I can give you a personal
experience I belong to the Masonic Lodge
located in
gwn and for a number of years we were
getting a partial abatement for our
facility um we were essentially as
representative Wilder indicated paying
only on the the Masonic Lodge portion
the dining hall portion um was we were
actually paying property taxes on our
recent uh most recent bill for the 2023
property tax year uh that exemption was
denied based upon interpretation of the
current statute and what's been
transpiring thank you further questions
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony thank you I appreciate the
milbrand good afternoon my name is
Donald milbrand I live in Bristol New
Hampshire I am a Mason but I wanted to
give a brief testimony to the committee
and I thank you for listening to me uh
from my experience of 12 Years on the
Bristol select board Bristol has a very
good relationship with their local
Masonic Lodge uh annually we have to do
a uh a motion to Abate the taxes for the
Masonic lodge and we do that every year
um we also have a good relationship with
the lodge and that we have a me
memorandum understanding for use of the
parking lot as public parking and they
take care of some of the maintenance for
it uh I'm in support of this bill mainly
to make it easier and more consistent on
the towns so that uh I believe it was
mentioned for a parking they should have
that Portsmith should have negotiated to
have the taxes Abad that's not
permissible from my understanding of
Municipal law it the select board has to
every year move to Abate taxes so you
can't have a a memorandum including that
so Bristol has been fortunate in having
good town administrators that remember
it every year and it's also had good
select boards that understand the
significance of the contribution of the
Masonic Lodge and as I start to say I'm
in support of this bill just to make it
more consistent um and easier both on
The Lodges and on the select boards so
it's not a year-to year do we evate them
or not thank you very
much thank you are there any questions
seeing none I have just one quick one
selectman is is it your testimony am I
hearing it correctly that currently
towns or municipalities have the ability
to
actually uh I understand it would make
it easier but towns have the ability now
to issue abatements on Masonic lodges
and association yes all right thank you
very much further
questions seeing none thank you for your
test morning sir thank you uh last pin
card anybody else have pin cards need to
get them up over here last one I have is
Rogers okay you're
up couldn't quite make out the last name
on
floor
name thank Mr chairman members committee
for the record my name is George B
Roberts Jr I live in the town of
gilmington I'm for disclosure I was a
master of a lodge in Alon W Baki I'm
also an active member in Mount Lebanon U
also belong to other Masonic
organizations um um Shriners um other
organizations that I've helped organize
all Masonic
groups I think probably you're asking
yourself why are we here if what the
gentleman said
four is correct
Statewide that the Selectmen have the
ability to
Abate so I'll give you one example why I
think we're
here is a city of lonia hired in aaisa
because of its
size the appraisal came back
in the lodge in all cases had sent
previously a document which they
also reported to the chal trust division
of the Department of Justice
annually as a nonprofit
charity is adopted as an
organization and the organization owns
the building where the blue Lodge or the
lodge itself actually meets
upstairs and the basement is used for
multiple purposes including municipal
organiz a nonprofit
Etc so we got this notice that you now
have to pay this tax after we did all
that and they gave us two reasons one
which we found out was a clerical error
they misfiled our annual report going to
the the town or the city and the other
charity now I had understood like some
of the people here perhaps have
understood or and many Masons had
understood that the municipality can
make the decision and in fact some
towns the municipality does make the
decision sometimes it's 100% sometimes
it's some portion if it has a a lease to
another profit
organization that is taxed such as the
building that's multi- stored uh
wherever the lodge mates wouldn't be
taxed but the retail businesses down
below would be taxed on the same bases
is any other business in that town but
somewhere in the
line and I can find it in the statute
and I've done some
research that ability that we thought
selectman in city councils had to
immediately or originally Abate the the
taxes
evaporated and it evaporated when the
town of or the city of
lonia after more than 50 years and Lodge
has been there over 200 years but at
least after 50 years
decided that they owed the large owned
ta taxes on all the property including
the parking lots which are available to
the general public to fish off in park
and we pl them
ourselves so we met uh in a very cordial
manner with with a mayor he refer us to
the people who did the uh the appraisal
we met with that gentleman and he was a
very gentlemanly type of person um it
turned out that his father was a Mason
and his grandfather was but he wasn't
and I said you should
be and he said well can Cloud the is
that's another issue but why are now we
being taxed why
now and he said the P part which I I I
mentioned earlier was in inaccurate
because the the misfiling of our
report with the charitable trust
division of Department of
Justice that was inaccurate uh because
that was misfiled that is a copy we gave
to the city annually on an annual basis
and that we weren't
charitable so here's what's going
on as towns get n get state appraises or
organizations to praise the appraiser
looks at it and he said personally from
my point of view If I Was A city
councilman had the authority I would say
these portions of your property are not
taxable but I can't cuz I'll lose my
license if I do and I said why would you
do lose your license he said because the
the division or the the Department of
Justice has a special board they call it
which is used to be an old board that
took that the made repayment for land
that was taken for highways primarily
now has all these tax exemption requests
going to them bypassing the
Community which was not the history
before so this is tumbling in from town
to town as these appraisals are being
done because they say they have decided
that you're not
charitable now the they is the
board you would have to appeal to them
first after amount of money spent for
legal counsel you don't want to go there
without
they can easily turn you down because
they can say your chapter your chter
your
organizational organization is not
specifically a charity under the the
Hampshire law that's why you have this
bill so it really isn't anything new
from what the authority used to be from
the municipality but somehow the
legislature allowed that authority to be
taken from the
municipality and some might say well
that's may be a good idea maybe there's
preferences but you know every exemption
is open to public examination all these
requests for exemptions under charitable
uh exemption have to have the documents
of all your money all your expenses and
I can tell anybody the Masons is not a
smoking and drinking club by any means
they have high value system which I I
appreciate and I think many people on
nun Masons appreciate but they're not
just there to socialize because when you
look at these
organizations that have limited
membership they are giving
specifically five times the amount of
money in many cases than the taxes would
allow them
because they're giving it away but
they're not being called
charitable am I Lodge you give them
Meals on Wheels they give hands across
the table which is somewhat similar they
give to the Isaac club which is for
people who drug abuse and on and on and
on and all these social organizations
are always wrapped around the
communities where the lodge is located
within the Bap County in my my case
because it's the only Lodge to build in
that county so we we generally try to
keep it within that Community rather
than give it to the American Cancer
Society and the hot all which great
organizations this little
organization is giving Almost 100% of
his assets every year liquid assets
every year to charity in the
community okay so why should you still
be in that situation or why should we
change the law why should you make the
law that you can stay in the in the
condition to give money is that in many
cases if you do the
math the amount of taxes that the
community
receives is less than the amount of
money that the lodge generates for the
social services within
the loc local what they are give you one
case the Masons and the Ells got
together we raised $5,000 for the uh New
Hampshire Grand estate Children's
Alliance this just W it took a massive
amount of effort but we had a concert
and we gave $55,000 big deal yeah and
you look at the other organizations that
give 50 to 60 or more thousands of
dollars that impact has a greater impact
because they're given to local
organizations that spend the money
locally Help the People locally and are
not drifting off to some National
Organization where they spend 60% for
administrative
costs we don't charge administrative
costs for what we do so in any way you
work
it if you pass the bill you can
straighten out I believe some of these
problems that some of the towns have had
still Selectmen or giving exemptions to
some but the day will come when they'll
say they had to do it here there was no
appeal or they did appeal and the state
said you're not in this right category
because the way you wrote your chapter
or your Charter or your organizational
network doesn't say that your
charity because Masons don't say they're
a charity they give charitable efforts
to the community so I'd ask you to to uh
support this
bill not just for Masons but to support
this bill for the communities because
when the it isn't just a small number
but the small number that are
contributing just don't give cash they
give time and all these volunteer
organizations they give their locations
free in many cases don't charge anything
in our case the city of Lon gets a huge
parking lot that we pl for free and they
want to tax the parking lot which
doesn't make sense so uh I think if you
pass this bill you will clarify the
authority thank you very much thank you
questions repr
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
so Corporation is is not my area of of
knowledge but I'm looking under our New
Hampshire statutes in chapter
292 corporations associations and Etc
then if you go under a voluntary corop
corporations and associations there's a
section that deals with charitable
corporations is it possible for Masonic
um lodges or Masonic associations to
I guess incorporate under this section
and then that takes care of this you're
not a charity you are a charity could
you explain that good
question
Masons are not organized as a charity in
their organiz fraternal organizational
setup however they do support and urge
The Lodges to be charitable
in the the one case I know
recently the auditor
said well your organizational chapter
doesn't on the bottom say when you
devolve or dissolve or when there's
demolution that you must give that money
to another
charity and they went one step further
they said you can only be organized for
effort and I didn't understand where
they had that legal power to say that
except when a bureaucracy makes a
decision and you trying to change it not
fight them but trying to change it you
need legal counsel in this case they're
going to send you directly to the
Department of Justice which is always
going to uphold by saying it doesn't say
this in your CH therefore you're not
chable that's the reason for the bill so
the the answer is that unless you
specifically organize a certain way and
and dissolve a certain way right now the
state doj subdivision of that board will
not recognize you as a charity and will
say no to your appeal for
exemption representative major thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question are my dues to my Lodge tax tax
deductible no thank
you oh and I I just and with one thing
of this hisory sir no huh I'm sorry I
chairman are
the organizational Charters or mission
statements contained within are they
identical for each Masonic Lodge or
each Masonic
Association I I can only address that in
in two cases um I was involved
in two lodges but were owned by
associations which you had to be a
member of that
Lodge so it seemed that was one and the
same except for organizational purposes
that an organization was created and in
both cases
all right through the language after you
get through the the the the the purposes
of Brotherhood and
charity specific language about making
efforts to better the
community but that was not enough for
the State of New Hampshire they want you
to be charitable charitable only they
don't want you to be organized for a
fraternal organization to get together
and talk about the things that you have
great
value and by doing that they're
saying you'll never get in that c
category because we're eventually going
to say no to everybody the way your
Charter is written one two organizations
I know of why they have that all the way
through the language of charitable
purposes and and meet for that purpose
because they weren't dissolved to go to
another charity they turned them down
followup Mr chairman
followup out of curiosity why don't you
organize as a
501c3 well is a grandmas still
here but uh you could
uh Masons first were
organized as a Brotherhood as you'd say
and they are open to everybody of every
religion and Creed
race sir I'm gonna you up one sec the
quest specific question was yeah about
organizing under a 5013c if you don't
know the answer that's fine well I have
to get to there okay if you could okay
because fairly quickly because of the
nature of that
organization they were organized Grand
lodges were organized for that
purpose despite the fact they gave
charity if you say well you have to be
organized as a charity as a Grand Lodge
the Grand Lodge does not uh comply to
that strict standard of being charitable
charitable only thank you very much
thank you I hope that help further
questions seeing none thank you very
much your testimony anybody if you have
any further information at some point
you'd like to send it in just send it
into the committee
okay okay with that we're gonna close
attending okay our next hearing was
supposed to start at 1:30
lales
hey yeah we need we need everybody who's
not on the next hearing if you want to
have discussion you're welcome to do it
outside
please
okay representative
Brown These are the wrong pink cards for
on yeah I've got one for 1210 you you
gave 1120 also you can put those back on
sheet well same
numbers okay we're gonna go ahead and
open up the public hearing on HB 1210
relative to the election of straford
County Commissioners uh representative
bargan thank you thank you very much Mr
chair as you know but maybe not
everybody else in the room knows have to
say it officially I'm representative
Timothy Oregon from straford County
District 10 which is the town of Durham
which actually inspired the fact that
it's a town is the third largest
municipality in the uh in straford
county and actually probably caused some
difficulty always caus this difficulty
registering because there's no way to
split it up into multiple pieces like
the three cities um so um I know I know
I'm in somewhat awkward position of
trying to overturn a bill they which was
originally your idea Mr chair but um
anyway I'm I'm basically just trying to
put the straford county commissioner
districts back the way it was for many
years I think as far as I can tell is
from the beginning of times I haven't
found any record of when they did it
otherwise um which is of one at large
district and there's many reasons why at
large district is the way to go for
straford County but one of them is of
course it has a 0% those of you who
follow R districting know you're
guaranteed a 0% population deviation
um so anyway we're the only we're the
only one of the 10 counties which elects
three County missioners at large um and
actually I'm Prejudice you know I'm from
straford County so I think that's the
best of the 10 counties but actually
think that's probably how all the
smaller counties should choose their
Commissioners um I mean maybe it makes
sense for Hillsboro OR Rockingham but I
don't think it makes sense for any of
the small counties and we're like an
average size we're exactly almost
exactly average we're close to 10% of
the population of the state
um one thing's unique about it there
isn't really any good way to split the
county into three uh pieces um it's twoo
large of cities Rochester and do have
almost the exactly the same number of
residents and I guess so those you have
written testimony direct your attention
there's a little spread sheet in the
back with the towns ranked in order by
uh by by the towns and cities ranked in
order by population and showing what the
what their percentage of the population
is anyway so um do do and Rochester have
almost exactly the same number of
residents each have 25% of the total
population that's 50% of the population
of the county and 50% of the work the
County government does right there
um My Town Durham it calls itself a town
but for most terms of its governance it
really is a city it main differences
aside from uh aside from labeling or
sign the fact we label oursel a town we
we don't have a mayor we have just have
a Town Council chair but that's not
quite the same thing as a mayor and uh
we also have no Wards and the lack of
wards is Cru W talking about this bill
because you can't divide Durham up into
multiple pieces when you're diving up
the electoral districts and um we're a
significantly larger than the smallest
city which is summersworth so Durham has
almost 12% of the population
summersworth has uh 9% of the population
so collectively those three cities in
Durham collectively comprise 7 1% of the
County's population and also like a
little complication when you
redistricting is there's the town of
Rollinsford which is surrounded entirely
by do and summersworth and then also by
Maine um and there's also Madbury which
uh mad it's also Madbury which just
small town just south of south of just
south of Durham and then there's also
actually if you count Madry durman Le
and Rollinsford uh I haven't added up
the exact numbers but it's close
probably close 80% of the state's
population are those like in that half
of the of the county
so uh all three of the Mayors they all
expressed their opposition to dividing
their Community County Commissioner
districts um and actually I think they
weren't thrilled that they were divided
between the State Rep districts that and
um also like historically the
Commissioners the county delegation and
municipalities have always worked
together well they've always had a good
working relationship and there's broad
support for leaving things they are and
I would say not much support for making
the change that um was done last year so
the legislative history of the recent
redistricting plan is uh short but
convolute HB 270 was sponsored by by you
Mr chair and five other straford County
Republicans um all I think either from
Rochester or from the northern part of
the county um that bill at a hearing
which I was doing something else that
day so I didn't even attend the hearing
though I've watched the YouTube video
and looked at the bill file um and it
was retained in committee a week after
its hearing and that seemed to be the
end of it um three months later however
in early may pretty close to the end of
the 23 session Jim Gray set the chair of
the senate election law minicipal
Affairs committee hly revived The
Proposal embodied in 270 as a non-gain
amendment to a bill called HB 270
hp75 and uh that was hurly passed on
Party Line votes in the Senate um and
there were there were three didn't get
to have a hearing in the house because I
guess they already had a hearing on on
almost tical Bill already but there were
three procedural votes and they were all
division votes I don't know exactly who
voted how but the they appear to be
Partyline votes judging from the numbers
I mean there may have
been I'm just speculating maybe a few
Republicans who flipped one way and a
few Democrats who flip the other way but
it was almost exactly the same as the
party division of the people who are
sitting in the room pressing their
buttons that day
so and this of course passing a
registrating plan in the middle of the
10year census cycle is highly unusual of
course as you know Mr chair you are I
believe the vice chair of the house
redistricting committee and um they're
usually um only taken up immediately
after the desal desal census most
recently in 20 the 2020 census and uh so
first of all the issue of changing the
at large election of the straford County
Commissioners never came up at all
during the redistrict debate which is
um mostly in the last few months of 2021
and the first half of
2022 um of course you were circumspect
on mentioning that at those hearings
I've looked at the bill files but other
members did come right out and say it
that something that changed in second
half of 20202 was uh the uh introduction
of the new nursing home plan which has
been very controversial to say the least
the uh and that was the supported by all
three of the com coming County
Commissioners who are all Democrats and
uh has for various reasons been
vehemently opposed by the Republican
minority County delegation I'm not
really here to litigate that that's
something that's going to be resolved uh
probably probably later this year or
pretty soon anyway or early next year so
it's going to
be once you hold your testimony there
we're here to talk about the election of
straford County Commission nursing home
so I'm just saying that's that
we will speak to the bill yeah that was
one items that are unrelated to the bill
that was one of several issues that uh
did come up during the HB 270 and 75
hearings um members of the straford
county delegation did uh directly refer
to that and they also there's a few
other uh few other there's a few other
uh minor issues or well smaller issues
anyway so that's uh and uh anyway this
there that I don't have to go going to
be more the nursing home that's in the
process of being resolved um also
probably something I don't have my
written tell someone to explain exactly
how the legisl legislation works the
legislation passed in
2023 well took effect 60 days after
signed by the governor but it it applies
only to the upcoming election in 2024 so
right now the at large districts are in
place you know the commissioner seats do
not become uh are not vacated um if if
if it's too late in the I think it's too
late in the uh cycle now to do it but if
for some reason one of them uh resigned
or whatever uh we would still choose it
according to the at large District so
that there would be and also if this
bill passes as introduced um it would
probably not be signed until after the
filing period for the upcoming elections
is so actually we would be unless uh
unless either this committee or you know
the senate election law missal Affairs
committee makes major changes or at
least changes the effective date we
would be having an election with the
three districts in September and then
General November then we would go back
in 2026 um if you're to if you're to
implement this for 2024 which I've in
favor of you first of all you'd have to
get it through the process a lot quicker
than I expect it's going to and you'd
have to like put in some contingencies
uh and I I discussed that with the
Secretary of State's office who didn't
really take position one way or the
other but they did tell me that just
this was the best way to handle the
effective datea issue so that's uh
that's basically my uh that's basically
my summary I know you put a lot of work
into putting this plan together I will
say one thing is uh the plan obviously
it's unpopular first of all because it's
been this way for 50 years or more and
most most people liked it the way it was
um also the plan that was introduced it
just barely meets the standard
statistical requirements for district
and I do and I guess you pointed out Mr
chair correctly you apparently use the
same redistricting software I did that
if you didn't split any cities you'd
have a uh de population deviation of
13.07% I so recall I got exactly the
same number from the software that you
got so we uh but if you although
actually if you just you could have
split summersworth into and gone a
slightly smaller deviation but I I I
like the at Large districts with the 0%
deviation so I'm I'm not introducing my
alternative plan I'll just mention that
in case if that's route you want to go
town to there other ways to split up the
county so that's my that's my testimony
so I'd be happy to answer any questions
any are there any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony all right thank you do you
have a a card represented
Potenza no I don't have
hers I think I think I pass mine around
yours I'm just trying to go in the order
that we're supposed to
hear representative penzo if you're
going to speak on it speak and uh make
sure you just give me a pink card before
you
it thank you Mr chair my name is uh
represent pres ative Kelly Penza
straford District 19 I wasn't prepared
today to speak on this because I it was
kind of a surprise um I was at all of
the testimony uh for your committee for
I guess it was called
hp75 uh I was also in the senate for
that as
well I won't be long-winded here this is
really an essence of fairness and and
balancing things out and why straford
county is the only County that has an
atlaw large in in regards with voting
people have been disenfranchised
especially in the small towns all of
the all of the emphasis is always on
Durham uh
summersworth uh do and Rochester and
it's just it's just really not fair um
there's been a lot of things that have
happened in straford County um which you
guys know from the news I really think
that we should be spending our time on
that and not on on this again because
this is now settled um it's just it's
just really sad in Milton Milton Mills
uh Farmington barington Lee um there's
just been a lack of attention for the
smaller towns in straford county and
because unfortunately the most votes
come from those four that I told you and
so when you run at large the people's
voice is not being being heard and
that's the taxpayer and that's who I
have a fiduciary responsibility to um
there's been a lot of talk about this
just even regards with tax caps not
being um you know because we we only
care really about the tax caps in the
cities that were you know when the
county raises their stuff it's going to
be raised like 4.2% but we don't care so
much about the small towns that have
instituted a tax cap and they're going
to get hit hard so this just levels the
playing field it it's it's really not a
um it's not a partisan issue it's an
issue of fairness and um and I just I I
hope that uh you guys move in expedient
to legislate and that we can move on to
bigger better things in straford
County thank you for your testimony any
questions representative potenzo see
none thank you very much for your
testimony next uh commissioner George
mcgis
uh represent uh please turn on your s
I'm
sorry uh members of the committee and Mr
chairman my name is George mcis I'm
chairman of the board of County
Commissioners in straford County I'm a
former two term member of this house I
served on this Committee in the 1970s
I'm also former two-term mayor of the
city of Dober I'm here in support of
this bill uh for a number of varying
reasons uh which I'd like to go over
with the committee and answer any
questions you may
have historically in New Hampshire I've
served on the board of County
Commissioners in straford county for 20
terms almost 40 years historically
what's happened in New Hampshire is
whenever a county decides it's going to
deal with the commissioner districts
that's always been handled by the county
delegation historically if you go back
and look at the history the county
delegation would meet and discuss
whether they should have districts and
not districts and how they wish to uh uh
elect their
Commissioners uh and then that
delegation would move that proposal
forward and that's been the case uh
throughout history in this particular
case during the redistricting
process uh the committee met in in do
and had a public Hearing in do uh uh and
there was no uh public outcry or public
comment from anyone about creating
districts in straford County for the
County
Commissioners uh County Commissioners in
straic County have been being elected at
large since
1856 uh and even during about 1880 when
Caroll County and bellnap County were
created from straford County the
Commissioners remained elected at large
the major reason for that was because in
order to to meet the new one man one
vote rules that were putting together
put put in about 50 years
ago you had to meet certain criteria and
one of those criteria in order to have
that happen in straford County was you
had to divide the cities in half which
uh which uh is what happened last year
uh with with the bill that was uh that
was formulated out of the
Senate but the county delegation is our
County delegation has never even met on
this bill number one last year's bill or
this year's Bill uh there's kind of a
misnomer going on around that that
straic County will never elect a
republican uh and the small towns are
never represented that's just that's
just not true uh I served with Leo lard
who was a former state senator a former
member of this house he served on the
commission with me until his death he
was from the town of
Milton I served over the Republican on
the commission who was from straford his
name was C schroer normally when the
Republican Party puts up someone who was
worth who has been worthy of voting for
them most of the time they they've won
we had a Sheriff a a republican sheriff
in straford county for decades we had
two of them in recent memory uh Sheriff
Harold Knight who was from Madbury one
of the smallest towns in straford
county and Sheriff eses who served for
about 20 years he was a republican he
was from the town of
Milton so this idea that sh just doesn't
elect Republicans is just it's just not
accurate uh second thing that I want to
mention if I may is
that the process of jury mandering
districts out of the cycle is a very
slippery
slope I've discussed this with many
constitutional attorneys
and the slope that we're on here is that
if there's a change in control of the
parties in either the house of the
senate in the future if you will allow
this jury mandering to take place out of
the cycle it allows that party to again
rejer Mander those districts
again now the Supreme Court has ruled in
2004 that that was unconstitutional once
the legislature has met its statutory
obligation by setting up
districts uh that it's met its obl ation
and it shouldn't be done again until the
next federal
census straven County was voted on the
district was to remain at
large that was brought forward by the
committee and passed by the
legislature and now we've in the off
year and then then the following year uh
they decide the legislature decideed to
take this particular
action there's many of us number one who
believe it's
unconstitutional I have been not I have
been contct conted by hundreds and
hundreds of Voters in straford County
who have called our office and very very
upset about the fact that they can't
vote for all three County Commissioners
anymore if you were have hold up Hearing
in straford County regarding this bill
you would have
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly support to
leave the way Commissioners are elected
alone
the the amendment that was passed last
year that came out of a committee of
conference uh the bill out of a
committee of conference in the Senate we
were given there was harm created as a
result of that those amendments we were
told at the time by Senator gray that we
had to agree to his uh jury mandering of
straford County uh to prevent the three
of us from having to run against each
other two of us are going to have to run
against each other uh in a primary now
the way the bill was designed it was
designed this way for Pure political
reasons
Senator gray offered an amendment uh
during the committee of conference that
would prevent all three existing
Commissioners from having to run against
each
other but he did so in a form of
blackmail for lack of a better term he
simply said you either agree to us or
we're going to leave this alone which
created harm that I'm sure the courts
are not going to accept because of that
basically you you need to take it or
leave it type of
attitude
so
uh in discussing with the association
for counties uh this concern and dealing
with in talking with legal counsel it
opens up an interesting dichotomy for
the legislature moving
forward if this is allowed to stand
there are some that say that there's a
position that they take that say well if
we've never touched it if we never if we
didn't deal with it we can change it
whenever we want and that's a very
slipper slope you're on okay the Supreme
Court says you can't do that you do it
once and they've done it once in
straford left it alone and they came
back and wanted to play with
it if you allow that in every County
every
County through this precedent would be
allowed to change the election of any
District that was not changed in the in
the as a result of the last
redistricting which means basically if
they didn't mess with it left it alone
that they would be allowed to come back
and change it now there was many
commissioner districts in the in the
state that were not
changed but they could be by setting
precedent in this manner now whether
they'd be challenged or not in court is
that's a separate issue but it would
allow a party in power to do this and
the Supreme Court has been pretty clear
about this saying that you can't do this
you can Jer Mander at once if the party
in power is in power at the time at the
time that the district initial districts
were established you can jury Mander it
then but you cannot do that you can't do
it after the fact which is what this
bill did it did it all after the fact uh
once it and we believe it's
unconstitutional so the association of
counties has looked at this and
unanimously uh support this bill uh to
try to find a legislative remedy uh
without having a legal
remedy uh and uh so I'm bringing that to
your attention because of the harm it
created uh the way it was done the
process that was used there was no
Hearing in straford County at all for
the people of stra County to weigh in it
was done by a a creative legislative
process I'll give Senator gray a pat on
the back for
that but it's Constitution ality is in
question and I think the the legislature
should write
it um we appear here I'm here with my
colleagues commissioner Rolo and
commissioner Watson we're not they're
not going to plan on testifying because
they don't want to repeat the issues
that I put out uh in front of you uh but
I want to play lay aside this misnomer
that a republican can't get elected in
straford County that's just it's just
not accurate it's not historically
accurate uh and uh there is
there's a reason why we've had a his
history in straford county of being a
very Progressive County and and leading
this state on issues like Drug Court
mental health court I could go on and on
and on the reason for that is because
the County Commissioners aren't dealing
with their own
districts I've been president of the
association of counties I've been
president of the County Commissioners
Council in this state for 30 years and
in all those other counties those the
Commissioners who elected our districts
protect their own
districts it it causes
dissension it causes uh the ability to
deal making to to occur we don't have
that in straford County because we all
work for the same constituency in the
end you don't have that happening in
other counties and if you look
historically what's happened uh you'll
see some political dysfunction and
always the public always has an
opportunity to go in and vote and change
it but in straford County it's Unique
because in straford County the voter has
the opportunity to vote for its
executive branch it can change the
executive branch with its vote and being
a a student of history and of the
Constitution I appreciate the fact that
I have that ability to be able to
control the executive branch with my
vote and I and this bill last year took
away that that right for tens of
thousands of
people so I'm hoping that you will
reconsider the bill uh and vote ought to
pass on this particular and I'll be
answer happy to answer any questions you
may have thank you for your testimony
questions representative
Brown thank you for taking my question
Mr chairman um how are your state
representatives elected in Stratford
County they're elected some are elected
in the by the municipality summer and
districts thank
you f the questions seeing none thank
you very much for your testimony I have
Horan
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Kate Horan I'm here
on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of counties uh commissioner
mcis is our current president of our
commissioner Council and the association
did look at this bill very closely and
does support it they have a lot of
concerns about the precedent that was
set last year in terms of doing uh
setting districts outside of the
redistricting formal process uh I will
conclude my testimony there uh
commissioner McClair has covered many of
the points and I know you're running
behind so I don't want to drag this out
any longer than it needs to awesome
testimony thank you very much any
questions for Miss
forgan not seeing any thank you very
much for your testimony yes we are
running behind and with that that closes
the hearing on HP 1210
we will start HB uh 1120 in just a
couple
minutes
okay we're going to go ahead we are
behind uh going to open up the hearing
on HB
1120 repealing the provision that
requires the reflection of Municipal
body votes on warrant articles I do
believe the prime sponsor is sitting in
floor thank you Mr chair good morning Mr
chair committee members and guests today
I'm here sponsoring a bill um to stop
election heing uh I am representative
Ron Dunn from
Londoner and I believe that this will
stop election heing this bill that I
proposed
HB 1120 will repeal the provision that
requires the reflection of Municipal
body votes on warrant articles this will
repeal
RSA 32 colon 5 comma V A and
B this repeal will not stop any
municipality from voting on Warren
articles it will just prevent them from
printing them on the ballot people can
still watch municipalities can still
vote and they can still see these votes
live they can see them on YouTube they
can read in the paper they can online I
Believe by printing it on the ballot it
is election heing so all this repeal
does is just prevents it from being
printed on the
ballot um give you a quick example from
my town currently we have Warren article
number three uh we're asking the voters
to appropriate $2.9
Million last month on this warrant
article Our Town Council voted Town
Council voted 5 budget voted 70 in
favor these votes could all be seen live
or in person or on YouTube and I don't
believe they need to be printed on the
ballot when these items are printed on
the ballot I believe it becomes election
heing a example um Mrs Smith comes to
vote uh she's heard about Warren article
3 but she's still unsure what to do she
reads Warren article 3 and Noti is the
last thing the very last sentence on the
warrant article is Town Council voted 5
bud budg committee voted seven all she
knows Hey Ron Dunn is my town
counselor I like him I'm going to vote
in favor of
this how is it any different than me
standing right there next to her in the
ballot Booth telling her to vote for
this my vote is on that ballot saying I
wanted this I voted for it so Mr Smith
comes in and says okay yeah I I like him
I'm going to vote for
this um I'm not allowed to wear a pin or
a hat or bring a sign into the
electioneering Booth but my my vote is
on that
ballot
um I submit to you that my vote on the
ballot has much more power than any sign
or pin or any sticker or hat that
somebody might
wear um I've done a lot of research on
this throughout the United throughout
New Hampshire and I found that over in
my research over 95% of the time the
municipal body and the budget committee
however they vote is how the warrant
article will turn
out so if the municipality votes in
favor the people vote in favor of it
they vote against it most times it's
voted
against currently in New Hampshire the
Miss bodies are required to vote on
warrant articles these individual votes
are printed on the ballot thus when a
private citizen goes into the voting
booth they can see how the municipal
bodies voted and how the budget
committee voted on these warrant
articles these registered voters have
the potential to have their vote swayed
in the ballot Booth when they see how
their municipal government and budget
committee
voted all this all this bill does is
remove it from being printed on the
ballot it does not stop any municipality
from voting on it and I believe that
when the vote is put on the ballot it is
election heing thank you for your time
this afternoon and I'll take any
questions thank you representative dun
representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question what if we were just to remove
the voting record from the ballot itself
and just leave the regular warrant
article on there the question thank you
for the question that's
acceptable representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so if I
understand your testimony correctly you
said that a person can
attend a meeting in person or they could
watch it live stream um or a recording
later and they can observe the governing
body and or the budget committee talking
about a budget or a warrant article and
then you know voting isn't that the same
they they still have that same knowledge
of that
vote I just I'm
not it's confusing to me so so they can
have the knowledge there but if they
didn't they weren't able to you know
attend the meeting in person or follow
up then somehow that's different if it's
printed on the warrant when they go to
vote if I if it is a SP2 town I'm
confused thank you for the question I'll
give you an example um direct to your
question so if a person is watching it
live the municipal body is voting and
they can see their vote they know how
their counselor their budget committee
voted okay if they are not there in
person they can read it in the newspaper
they can see it online or they can hear
from their local people that how they
voted okay that's about the same as
having someone holding a sign out front
of the polling place right saying vote
Yes on three okay my argument is when
it's put on the ballot in the ballot
Booth it's election earing I can't bring
a sign in and say vote Yes on three but
I can put my vote on that ballot and I
submit to you that my my vote is more
important than a sign out front um you
know if if I vote against something or
vote for something that has much more
impact swaying someone's opinion than a
sign or a pin or a hat I'm not allowed
to wear those into the election Booth so
that's my
argument repr
Gallagher uh so this bill is sounding
really familiar to me and I feel like
we've had a similar one to it before I'm
wondering if you looked into the
legislative
history um of other similar bills that
I've tried to do the same thing in the
past and um discovered what happened to
um any of those previous
versions thank you for the question ol
did not inform me of anything so I'm not
aware of
any representative
Guthrie thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for your
testimony do you realize that the
process is that the selectman the
council and the budget committee go
through a
process that they look at the
information that they have and the
warrant article that is presented to the
town deser don't you believe that the
they deserve the opinion of both those
bodies after all the work they've gone
through in the
finding out if that warrant article is
in fact in the best interest of the town
thank you for the question I absolutely
I said that in my testimony I absolutely
agree they should vote there's no
there's no question they should vote I
just don't believe it should be printed
on the ballot in the in the election
Booth followup go ahead how how then
would the voter get that information
that uh after the information that the
uh bodies have looked at that and either
vote yay or nay because I don't think
it's fair to assume that because it's
not that way in my town that every uh
recommendation is five or three to zero
sometimes it's four to two it's 3
to2 uh so uh I had a petition article
where it was one to two and it
P so I don't think don't you believe
that the people should have the right to
the deliberation of those two
bodies thank you for the question
absolutely I believe that that's what I
said in my testimony I absolutely
believe that 100% I just don't believe
it should be printed on the
ballot no no one more quick question no
Representative no no no yep uh
representative H so along that lines
because to what representative goth is
talking you could have a petition uh a
petition warrant that's placed on your
ballot but the petition warrant is not
supported by the governing body in which
case you can put an explan in on warrant
articles and maybe I hope I'm correct on
this but you can place an explanation
that sits at the bottom of the warrant
article and it in which case if it was a
petition warrant article and the
governing body did not in fact support
it you could place that language on
there so your your Amendment would strip
the ability of of the voter to know
whether whether it was recommended or
Not by the governing body on the thank
you for the question on the ballot sir
yes on the ballot it would not strip
them from their ability to learn that
through other means just not in the
ballot Booth representative
yull thank you uh thank you for taking
the question it seems like
um the issue is kind of at least I think
foreign to this this committee and much
more
um likely to to be handled by election
law committee where um there's special
Provisions for what can be done inside
of a ballot area versus outside of a
polling booth and you know in the public
in general and so would I be correct in
in in saying that you
are the only reason why you're putting
this forward is because of
the that distinction between what is
going on in the polling place and what
is allowed and disallowed inside the
polling place versus what is allowed and
disallowed out in the public as far as
uh electioneering because you can
electioneer outside of the polling place
which is completely legal but you can't
electioneer inside the polling place is
that my correct understanding of C the
thrust of your bill thank you for the
question so
my Crux of this question is is to repeal
that RSA that requires it to be printed
on the ballot this RSA says it must be
printed on the ballot so I just want to
repeal that so it is not printed on the
ballot that answers your
question representative Maj thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question just curious if you have
contacted Dr or the Attorney General
Andor the Secretary of State to to have
their way in I actually thank you for
the question I actually did speak with
Mr SC Secretary of State and uh I sat
down and had lunch with him we had about
a 20-minute conversation and he said
that he uh he sees both sides of this
issue and he said that he would not
support or uh he would he would remain
neutral on the on the
opinion repres kill thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my
question do do you to your recollection
when citizens put a petition and signed
signatures to get a war article on and
supporting an article are their names
printed on the ballot they are not thank
you for the question they are not
printed follow up Mr go
ahead and and you like that would be
electioneering if their names were
printed on the Bel right I agree with
you
sir uh representative
Gilman thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I come from an
sb2 town just had our delivery session
we had about 88 people people um in
November will have about 8,000 voters so
is your what you're getting at
um trying to get those other that that
the a printed version of slman voted 50
on this is uh affecting the decisions of
the
7200 that don't
come thank you for the question I
believe it does impact some people
absolutely thank you
representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question
so there's a
it is it your understanding that there's
a difference between a warrant and the
ballot the actual ballot that somebody
votes on in a voting booth thank you for
the question it's in our town anyway
it's the same thing Ian the warrant
article is printed on the ballot and you
vote right on it follow up go ahead
is it your understanding that not
all cities and towns municipalities are
SP2
correct represent VI Kell thank you
thank you for taking another question
um I'm just wondering about the the
impact of your bill I'm not sure that it
will have the impact that you're
intending so the law seems to require
the printing of the ballot but the
repeal of that does not forbid the
printing of it on the ballot and your
statement before seems like to say that
they may printed on the ballot in which
case it doesn't actually address your
your concern if the the legislative body
still chooses to print it on the ballot
even though it's not required is that
thank you for the question um
understanding I would just say that
if if it's repealed then they wouldn't
be required
to but yeah it could be but it wouldn't
be required right now it's required if
they cannot choose not to print it on
there represent
G uh so one point that's been brought up
is that um people can just uh watch the
deliberations on their live stream uh
how however we had a separate bill uh
before this committee that we referred
to um interim study
requiring um that municipalities do
Drive live streaming so wouldn't the
fact that um that bill or that other
legislators have deemed that um deemed
that bill to be necessary seem to imply
to you that no they can't actually just
watch it on the live stream currently
that there are some municipalities that
don't already live stream their um
deliberative
sessions thank you for the
question um if I understand your
question
correctly in that case they could see it
in the newspaper they could um they be
other methods for them to get reporting
on how we voted as as a body they
wouldn't have to printed on the ballot
for them to get the results there's many
other options for
them representa Guth thank you Mr
chairman my question got a little bit
longer because uh I I started to assume
that you assume that all the voters are
very
knowledgeable if what how would a voter
know how to vote if they're going to the
ballot to vote on that bond issue that
they don't want you know they're very
emotional about that so they go in and
they vote on that but they don't know a
darn thing about all the other warrant
articles how would they have some
guidance to vote on those other articles
thank you for the question I actually
believe that most voters probably come
in not knowledgeable so my feeling is
that by printing the ballot how we voted
on this has more power that I'm telling
somebody to vote on this because I voted
in favor of it and I believe that has
more power than any other method of
electioneering because they do come in
uninformed sometimes on these articles
like you suggesting I'm agree I agree
with you on that and I'm saying that by
printing my vote on this on this war
article it has much more power because
someone's going to say I know him and he
voted for this I'm going to vote for it
Point well taken thank
you seeing no more further questions
thank you very much representative dun
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee members I'm going to read you
the election law I'm going to read first
paragraph and um opening paragraph and
two because the middle one is about what
you're wearing but um for the Reon I'm
representative Christine Perez I'm from
London Dair representing District 16 in
Rockingham election ering means means
visibly displaying or audibly
disseminating information that a
reasonable person would believe
explicitly advocates for or against any
candidate political party or measure
being voted election earing includes but
is not limited to and this is the Clos
part so I'm going to go on to
Distributing or posting a card a hand
Bill a poster a placard picture pin
sticker circular or any form of
communication that a reasonable person
would believe explicitely advocates for
or against any candidate political party
or measure that being said and the fact
that you brought up about informed
voters I feel very strongly that we need
to have informed voters I think maybe if
we had informed voters
we're informed when we vote we look into
the bills and our informed voters and I
think this takes away from people um
actually going out and seeing what
they're voting on and why is that being
on that ballot any different than me as
an electorate official being out in
front handing out stuff which I'm
allowed to do handing out
recommendations for what warrant article
or what I should vote on it's really no
different now many
towns yes they put them on the ballot
but they also send out or have available
for people
information about what is being voted on
I have examples here actually they're
from Windam uh one is put out by the
school board one is put out by the town
that's where people can get their
information we in londondary have um
we're very fortunate that we have a
weekly newspaper uh that goes to every
home to inform them but I personally
feel that I want people voting in my
town or any Town who are informed who
are just not going in and following what
Ron Dunn put down because I don't always
agree with Ron Dunn I want people to be
informed and if you literally take what
the election provision is putting that
information on the ballot is definitely
a form of election earing thank you
thank you representative
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank you
binski good afternoon afternoon my name
is Richard binsky I am a resident of the
town of lary and for full disclosure I'm
the one that ask this to be brought
forward and the reason
being what was just read by
representative Perez is in contrast to
what is allowed to be done in the
ballot the state wants it both ways the
way it's written
currently the ballot when you have a
vote by the Town Council in your budget
committee I've talked to many of my
neighbors I'm
very involved in the town I've been the
town Treasurer and they say hey I voted
for S and Sh I said why well because of
what was on the ballot I said but you
aware this is what's actually going on
you didn't get the full truth and I'll
give you a couple examples I'll do this
as quickly as I can because I know
you're behind they say no we didn't know
that I just went by what they said now
also our budgetary committee in our town
is the vatory only they have zero
power so who cares what the vote is they
have no power that's actually on our
ballot this year to try to get it so
they do have
power so a couple of examples of why
this needs to go away back in 2019 we
had our Police Department put in for a
new generator for the police
station um they presented it a
deliberative session they presented it
as it's beyond its useful life that it's
had major repairs it needs to be
replaced none of which was true I was
not at the deliberative I wasn't able to
go but I watched it and I started asking
questions after they all approved it to
put it on the ballot the generator is a
commercial generator they're good for
about 30,000 hours if they maintain for
normal usage before they need anything
major as had 533 hours on it I asked for
the maintenance records took six months
for them to give it to me and only after
I gave him a 91a would they give me the
maintenance records maintenance records
showed exactly what I thought they were
going to show never been a problem with
the generator they replace the transfer
switch which makes takes the power from
the generator and puts it into the
building but that has nothing to do with
the generator so that was
$175,000 that got voted in it got voted
in by the people I could give you the
exact figures of you know who voted what
because they it was misrepresentative by
those in charge they knew they were
doing this because the town manager had
called one of the captains of the police
department said' we got extra money well
Town never has extra money it's taxpayer
money what do you need we need a new
generator so they come up they concocted
the story that wasn't true long story
short after I exposed all this and the
fact they said they were going to trade
the old Generator in to offset the new
one why would you trade it in if it's
beyond its useful life and no good they
were going to use the new one as a
backup to the backup
you can't always trust your elected
officials no offense I talk
bluntly hopefully they bleed you down
the right Road more times than
not so what happened they never spent
the money because they got exposed they
police chief come in and said oh I know
this is a CIP Capital Improvement number
one priority immediate need we have to
have it right away and after it was
exposed oh we'll take a look at this
again in 10 years but people voted for
it and there was kind of an uproar when
I put an article in the paper and people
said well I voted because they said 5
and I think it was 60 on the budget
committee on this particular vote I
didn't know so I voted the way they
voted get it off the ballot let people
educate themselves I educate myself on
everything been in town since 85 been in
New Hampshire since'
69 this year we have another Warren
article going on that's been
misrepresented they want to put pickle
ball courts in they went out and got
quotes they have a pickle ball committee
that's fine you know people want it
that's fine if they voted in they got
quotes on it that um for high and low
they got the quotes based upon the land
being ready to go that it's engineering
you know been done well it hasn't been
done the land's covered with trees they
haven't ex they haven't told people any
of this I've got the information here I
had to beg them for a week to give me
the minutes to the meeting and the
committee chair won't call me back for a
week I've been trying to get so they
voted and this wasn't a 5060 this was
like a 41 on the town to approved the
pickle ball courts you've been given bad
information and I think it was uh 43 to
approve it on the budget committee again
people go to the ballot they see these
votes printed there and they just go
along with it I talked to hundreds of
people in town and they say yeah I
didn't know so I just went with was on
the ballot they need to educate
themselves you know you shouldn't have
to you shouldn't have to beg people to
get educated when they go and vote
there's something on the ballot that I
don't understand I either know about you
know find out ahead of time or I don't
vote on it because I don't know what
would be right or wrong on that
particular warrant article this is
directly engineering even um there was a
letter that was we got
back from the
state
from oral
Finch uh Secretary of State's office New
Hampshire Law requires that the
government body and budget committee
recommendations be printed in the
warrant article on the warrant and on
the ballot while the recommendations may
fall within the definition of
electioneering the recommendations are
exempt from any prohibition that might
apply because the law requires them well
that's great and dandy and I understand
that but it's
in exact opposite of what your
electioneering laws say you can't have
it both ways so that's why I I brought
it Forward I know for a fact from
talking to many people they don't
educate themselves my own daughter and
son-in-law live in town they don't know
what's going on they come and ask me
they're like H we don't want to
know so if you have something that's the
last thing people say I don't know how
to vote so I'm going to vote you watch
If you eliminate that you're going to
see votes changing in
towns and yes somebody brought up or
what if they voted not to support
something
well I can't have it both ways and only
want it when it's seven you know 504 to
take it off and when it's 0 to five
against it you know have it on it's not
how it works people need to educate
themselves I'm going to be 64 years old
and I educate myself you can't you know
that's what you got to do so that is the
reason I brought it up it's in contrast
to the law it does influence people's
votes go out and talk to people and
you'll see that it
does thank you for your test
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony I have one more pink card on
ol my name is uh Jeremy Olsen I
currently reside in Manchester hillsb
District 22 good afternoon members of
the committee thank you for allowing me
to testify on this bill today I was the
lead plaintiff in a lawsuit against the
town of Grafton over this very issue
hp120 reverses the bad decision that
came out of that case the case was um
Jeremy Olson versus town of Grafton 168
NH 563 from 2016 the we had other
plaintiffs involved as representative
Tom PL uh Chris Ken jabish and our
attorney was Brandon Ross so um I moved
up to
graft I moved up to Grafton in the year
2010 and and I immediately began
attending the town meetings voting
getting involved in the town I actually
organized a group of people who were
interested in getting involved and one
of the things people like doing was
writing petition warant articles to get
on the ballot um I did this for four or
five years and it's a town of 1300
people and I got up to 50 people that
were interested in getting involved in
town politics we usually get about 35 of
these people to attend the sb2
deliberative sessions Grafton is a very
spread out Town it has 50 miles dirt
roads they actually say it has the most
dirt roads in the entire State and um so
I and a few of the other people we took
it upon ourselves to drive around town
ask people what they wanted to put on
the ballot then collect the signatures
because it took I think 25 signatures to
get something on the ballot and graft
and so me and like three or four other
people we went all over town helping
people get involved most of the waren
articles that we put on were things that
were to downsize or limit local
government things that our Selectmen
generally didn't like seeing appearing
on the B bot finally in
2015 the selectman decided to add quote
the selectman do not recommend this
article to every single one of the
articles that we put on the ballot there
were three other petition warant
articles that year from from other
people they didn't put a recommendation
one way or another on those articles
they only printed do not recommend on
every single one that I am the group of
people I was working with submitted they
didn't print a a vote t they just
printed do not recommend on every single
one and as um the representatives that
testified before us before me spoke that
I see that clearly as electioneering
they didn't like the kind of stuff we
were doing and they were just basically
trying to get their opinion inserted on
the ballot so that's what people see
when they're about to vote on it as
everybody else had already said nobody's
allowed like I can't go into the ballot
and say please vote Yes on my article I
can't hang something up in the ballot
box but the Selectmen essentially are
able to do that
um we researched the rsas we found this
very RSA is 32 colon 5 we spoke with a
um an attorney Brandon Ras he agreed and
we sued it ended up going to the um
Supreme Court and they um the way the
law is written all the combination of
Elections was the court admitted it's
vague it's contradictory and they
actually had to dig through State House
transcripts going back to 2009 it was
sb38 to find that the way this thing was
written actually allowed them to print
the recommendation on the ballot because
the way we interpreted and our attorney
agreed was that it was just about money
articles none of our articles were about
money but they still found a way to
print do not recommend on our articles
and the court affirmed that decision and
um after we lost that case I ended up
giving up trying to organize all these
people to put stuff on the ballot and I
ended up moving back to Manchester a few
years ago and um so I support this bill
AB absolutely 100% support this bill it
will prevent the Selectmen from what is
essentially electioneering on the ballot
people who want to place warn articles
on the ballot should feel free to do so
without feeling that they're being
interfered with by the town government
whom some of those articles are you know
trying to limit the power of and in the
the case I was working here this
directly led to a reduction in civic
participation in Grafton like I said we
had 35 people showing up at town meeting
most of those people stopped going to
town meeting self included after this
stuff happened one recommendation I
think would be if if this bill as it's
written is
unpalatable I'd recommend amending the
bill or amending the rsas to restrict
the recommendation so it's only on money
articles it does seem reasonable to me
that like on a money article say someone
petitions you know I want $6 million to
build a new library and the town doesn't
have the money that seems reasonable
that the budget committee might want to
be able to say we don't have the money
we recommend against like what they did
in grafted is these articles had nothing
to do with money and they just said no
no no no on every single one and every
single one did fail that year um thank
you for allowing me to testify today I'd
be more than happy to take any questions
thank you fa testimony representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question so would you think it
was reasonable for the Selectmen to put
on their website for instance what their
recommendations were and maybe a brief
expl explanation of what the reasoning
was as opposed to and then removing it
from the Articles themselves that are on
the ballot oh yes thank thank you for
the question um I absolutely think it's
reasonable if they want to discuss them
and then like they have meeting minutes
you know they have a selectman's meeting
in my town in that town every two weeks
and the meeting minutes will get
published on the website and if they
wanted to discuss them and just say like
we disagree with this here's why we have
a rationale for it if they want to put
that on the website that would be fine I
would have no problem with that if the
selectman want to stand out out in like
the electioneering allowed area on
Election Day and like hand something out
that's their business as long as they're
not F falling a follow some other law
that I'm not aware of I would have no
problem with that it's just that key of
it's it's literally printed right on the
ballot so people read this article and
then directly down there it says select
and say don't vote for this that's the
kind of thing that I and the other
people here to have a problem with thank
you representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question could you tell me
how many you gave it an example of um
petitioned warrant articles in the town
of graft
I think over a number of years how many
of those petition warrant articles were
advisory only versus something that were
actionable that is an excellent question
thank you for taking that when we would
go to deliberative session when they
went through the ball they would often
tell us this is advisory only many of
them in fact were advisory only so it
didn't even have an impact on the town
government if these things wereth to
pass um just a couple examples um one
thing like to see if the town will vote
to instruct the select board and budget
committee to work on reducing the budget
for by 10% over the next 3 years we
don't have the power to force it but we
would ask them to do that we had two or
three that would hold on it was the
question was more a little more specific
how many not so much getting into the
you yeah sorry um I probably say but
this particular year probably about 75%
of them would have been non would have
been advisory only there was one or two
that definitely were under specific rsas
that would order the town to do
something but most were um advisory only
thank you further
questions seeing none that was the last
pink card I had thank you for your
testimony with that the house Municipal
and County government
committee public hearing on HB 1120 is
now closed we will open up the next
Hearing in just a couple
minutes
be
read okay the time being after 2:30 when
this bill was scheduled to be heard um
it's a little past 3 so I'm going to
open the hearing on House Bill 1359
relative to the appeals of certain
zoning Decisions by a
Butters I recognize the prime sponsor
representative
turot thank you chairman power uh good
afternoon everybody representative Len
turkot I represent the District of
straford County uh District Four the
straford I'm here to introduce HB
1359 which is a
uh bipartisan bill as you will see by
the sponsors it also is missing a couple
sponsor ERS um the day before the
deadline we had still not received this
back and when I contacted
OS um I was told it had been sent to me
well it actually went to the other
representative turot so it was a
scramble to get the individuals on here
uh there were two other individuals in
this room who are originally supposed to
be on the
bill there are I was asked uh first
contacted by the New Hampshire Municipal
Association for the bill I am expecting
them the Bia some home builders uh that
will also uh be testifying in support of
this bill there are two parts to it I'll
start with the first one the first part
if you look on page one of the bill on
lines three and
four it removes the term or sent uh
three words any person AG reeved which
is Broad by any uh
definition and replaces it with the
applicant and a butter as defined in 62
uh 7 672 colon 3 we'll talk about that
one in a little little more detail in a
second the
other one that is changed is on that
same page line
16 and the wording any person directly
affected thereby is replaced with an
abutter as defined in the RSA which
we'll talk about in a minute both of
those terms are very vague uh there were
a couple of uh court cases that you will
hear about from others
um is really the main one of the main
here so as
written the reason I believe it's too
vague and let's go back to line three
and four any person AG greev so I live
in the town of barington I live on the
Southeast side of barington the other
side of barington is about eight miles
away what is any person AG
grieved can somebody on the other side
of barington create an excuse as to why
he's AG grieved by what I may be doing
on my
property um I I think under the current
language that can be made now remember
this these are these are rights um to
the appeal of the board of adjustment
this isn't this isn't going to change
how people are
notified um it's not going to prevent
them from speaking at a hearing it's
only going to be uh change the
individuals who can
apply uh for the appeal to the board of
adjustment or the motion of re-hearing
in the second
case
the second part now when that was
brought to me and I was reviewing a
couple of the cases that you will
probably hear about one was in seabook
and one was in the town of
Dover um by changing the first part to a
butter I went of course to the 672 colon
3 um definition of a a
butter in one of the cases it spoke to
being um
the current language where it says
directly across the street of stream
from and and one of the cases hinged on
the definition of being of of exactly
that and that was they were claiming
directly included
diagonally so as I started looking at
that I tried to come up with a little
bit of clarifying language of what is
exactly across the street or stream
mean we went through all kinds of
iterations and none of them really
worked very well now when you read
what's in there now starting on line
five it may sound confusing but it's
actually very very
definitive and simply what it says is
and I had planned to actually draw up
some examples and I will do that for
anybody who would like to see them later
but basically what it says is take a
simp simplistic
case I was recently down in Salem the
town of Salem on the main Dragon it was
an extremely wide road so if you had a
parcel a square parcel on one side of
that
road using this definition directly
across the street of
stream you go to the edges of the
property you draw a line perpendicular
across the
street any point that falls between
those two lines you're in a butter and
50 feet on either side of those lines
you're in a butter now that only applies
to across the street or
stream uh when we were developing this
language rep Uh current chairman power
and I discussed uh other um
potential uh properties with uh you know
50 foot rways in or entryways and
different things and we finally got it
to this definition um
which I think covers just about any
instance you can you know other other
issues that were brought up was okay
well why not diagonally across well take
Salem that was a a good is a good
example if you took and Drew a diagonal
from the the point on one side of the
that six Lane Street or whatever it is
down there in Salem and when diagonally
you could C
capture a property hundreds and hundreds
of feet down the street depending what
your definition of diagonal is is
diagonal 90 is it 60 is it 2 Dees so
we we eliminated the diagonal we also
talked about radi uh
radius radius from where that was a very
difficult one to do so by adding simply
this this definition of what across the
street of stream means in addition
what's already there we thought that was
uh more than adequate
to accomplish what we were trying to do
so again like I said we have other
people I know who are going to speak on
this that may or may not be more
um well spoken or
well uh aware of the couple of
these um Supreme Court decisions that
were done but I would certainly be open
to to any questions that you may
have thank you representative turot are
there any questions for the prime
sponsor representative Guthrie thank you
madam chair and thank you for your
testimony I just have a quick question
and it's because it's I don't understand
what's going on here are you looking to
include more and butters or limit the
amount of Butters who will will have uh
some justification should for be before
the uh uh the ab betters I mean the
board of adjustment excellent question
we're not trying to eliminate or
increase the number of abutters what
we're trying to do is Define the
abutters more
specifically um and at the same time for
the purposes of appeals and
rearings to
eliminate the terms any person AG
grieved which is
very broad as well as any person
directly affected thereby by making it
specific to the abutters and in
including a new definition in the
abutter followup Madam chair if I
may yes when you're referred I I didn't
look up the RSA so you can save me a lot
of time when we're talking about the
board of adjustments we're not talking
about the local Board of adjustment as
we know it we're talking about a another
appeals board is that
correct as far I I have mentioned this
to many people I Am brand new to the
municipal and County realm if you will
I've been on labor and other committees
for years um alls I can talk to is this
one is rights to appeal of the board of
adjustment and it's RSA
676 colon five I'm sure somebody else in
back would be way better at answering
that I wasn't clear I meant the town
Board of adjustment versus another Board
of
adjustment which is
it it's the one in 676 colon
5 no wonder you're chairman Mr chairman
thank
you further questions representative
majori thank you madam chair and thank
you representative for taking my
question which may may be getting down
to the weeds but but I'll but I'll get
to the salian point of the question I'm
only thinking from years on the planning
board where people read every word and
then and then try to find the the oops
of the loophole um and I'm thinking
specifically in the town of Northampton
we have minor sight plan review if a
site plan already exists and they want
to do a minor sight plan years later
that um that they may do that
um what happens if the grieved
party is contesting the boundary lines
would what where would the appeal go if
you are contesting the boundary lines
excellent question that I have no answer
for I do not know the answer to that
okay well again maybe somebody behind me
for that thanks I'd love to answer it
but I I don't know the
answer further
questions representative Tetra was your
hand up previously okay representative
Gilman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question
um I also have a problem with the any
person grieved um only and I understand
it's a catch all which is good uh
but you need the catch all because you
don't do you know it what happens
when uh property is owned jointly and
one of the property owners decides to
tear down a barn and the other property
owner is is uh upset about that they may
go to the zoning board to solve their
problem because it's
a piece of property that that's allowed
but not wanted by
both it's not a good example but um I'm
just saying
when there are situations that sounds to
me if if that's a question for me it
sounds to me more like a civil civil
action or a deed action rather than
something that would app app to this in
my
opinion representative Brown thank you
madam Vice chair
uh so the question is in regard to your
perpendicular line so let's say this is
a polygon a hexagon something like that
so those perpendicular lines are drawn
whatever whatever adjacent Corner points
they are is that correct that's correct
thank
seeing I have a
question so um I too am concerned with
the Striking of the in line three any
person AG reeved as well as in line 16
any person directly affected thereby and
the concern that I have is that there
could be um a project in town which
would
affect people within that
municipality that are not directly AB
butters for example if a neighborhood
were going to be put in and there's
concerns with the majority of our um
houses here in New Hampshire are on
Wells private Wells so something like
that would would affect people who are
not directly Butters who their Wells
they draw water from an aquafer an
underground natural aquafer would you be
open to an amendment that would
accommodate
um that would eliminate the overly broad
language that exists now um if it were
something
specific I would be potentially open to
that thank
you representative
K thank you madam chair thank you for
was there was some construction going on
in Hampton not too long ago a couple
years ago where this object was being
put up that um reflected the sun in a in
a in a way and the the people that were
being affected by that item weren't AB
Butters they were like pretty far
away so do you would you believe that
maybe this language exists to protect
people like that well what I would say
is that there's nothing that prevents
the
individuals I would imagine that would
come up at an
initial um hearing or whatever uh
initial Hearing in the town there's
nothing that prevents individuals from
testifying there's nothing that prevents
as we'll go in line four an officer
department head board Bureau of
Municipal there's nothing that prevents
them from doing the the appeal again
what this is trying to do is eliminate
the overly
broad language that could apply to just
about anything uh representative power
mentioned um you know open
to um you know an amendment if it's
something that's specific I I'm not
opposed to that what what the reason for
this language is to get rid rid of this
language representative
stavis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question um this
proposed Bill seeks to seeks to it
references 672 colon
3 and I'm looking for a kind of happy
medium between the any person AG grieved
and the more specific language which I
support but 672 three actually has a
little bit more expansive language than
what is proposed in your bill because it
says shall include any person who is
able to demonstrate that his land will
be directly affected by the proposal
under consideration would you be
amendable to including that language as
an
amendment um I'm looking at
6723 the definition of a
butter I don't see that language that
you just read I'm I'm reading it
RSA the definition of a butter oh yes I
do see
that but what it says is for the for the
testm only only and not for the purposes
of
notification I think it makes the the
differentiation there
right but that differentiation is not
made in your bill I I couldn't hear that
one sorry that differentiation is not
I'm sorry
followup Madam yes uh I don't see that
definition in your bill either unless
it again I'm a little confused um on the
second page under the abutter that
language is already
change thank you
are there any other questions for the
sponsor seeing none thank you thank you
madam
chair so next I have Mr David juv who
bill I fromp Association he's going to
be talking a lot of things that I'd like
to
so you would like to wave off your
appear okay that'll be
fine so next I will call Mr n Grace from
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
he's here to testify in support of the
handout thank you madam chair n Grace
for the municipal Association we do
support the bill
um I I just want to explain briefly um I
do have a handout that explains kind of
the origination of uh the ideas behind
this bill it marries two different
things um so first I'll start with the
definition of a butter I will admit to
all of you that I am not an engineer but
uh I understand that the chair has
training as an engineer and uh and did
some drawings for me that made a lot of
sense
um so a couple years ago um back in 2021
this the New Hampshire Supreme Court
decided the SE Brook onetop case in that
case uh they determined that the current
definition of a butter does not include
properties that are diagonal um in going
in which doesn't make a whole lot of
sense when you think about it because
that means that the table that's
diagonally from my property here this
table is not in a butter even though it
would logically touch um so the language
on page page two would seek to uh alter
that to include those properties as well
as other relevant properties that may
not be captured by the current vague
definition the second thing that the
bill does is the changes to the any
person aggrieved uh any person directly
affected language um to change that to
the applicant and a butter or uh the
municipality
and part of the reason for that is over
the course of the spring and summer
there was a special committee on housing
that
investigated um some of the concerns
with uh let's say a dir of of housing in
our state um and one of the things that
was discovered during that process was
that uh back in the
1970s there were what are frequently
termed as starter homes small homes or
affordable homes that is homes less than
1,400 Square ft that were built that
were about a quarter of the number of
houses built um for a number of reasons
those have become not very economical to
build and as of um about 2010 there less
than 10% of the houses built given our
current housing situation the market
would dictate that those are the kind of
houses that firsttime home buyers are
looking for so one of the questions that
arose was well what policy conditions
existed in the 1970s that were then
changed that may have affected this type
of building and one of the things we
were able to identify was that the
legislature changed the statute um for
who has the ability to appeal a local
land use board
decision and instead of saying what it
used to say it broaden the language to
say any person AG
grieved and in development time is money
and so the longer a project takes the
more money that the developer has to lay
out for it the less economical it
becomes the less likely it is they're
going to build that small starter home
that we're hoping for them to
build so in looking at
the statutes back in the 1970s one of
the what I'm going to call obvious um
changes was to change the um any person
AG grieve to back to what it had been
before because when that was challenged
at the New Hampshire Supreme Court back
in the 70s the Supreme Court created a
four-part test and one part of that test
um
essentially allowed someone to who was
not directly affected by the applicant
property but was just someone out there
in town to start the process of delaying
that project going forward and as I said
time is money so even though they were
not going to win that case even though
eventually it would get kicked out of
court it was costly enough that the
developer was no it was no longer
possible for the developer to build what
they were hoping to build which
unfortunately is often these small
starter homes
so we have quite a coalition of
supporters behind this legislation
because we think it will Target what we
want to Target in the state which is
development of these small homes that
are affordable to the average person the
average family and we'll see more of
those built if this bill passes I'm
happy to take any questions the
committee may
have other there any questions for Mr
Grace representative
lales
thank you for taking my question
um I'm not I'm not making the Nexus
between the
bill and additional starter homes could
you put that and i' I've read through
your
testimony uh I just don't I don't see
the
connection
so there are people
who don't like development of small
homes homes because they often occur in
uh small developments um and uh and one
of
the tactics that they've used to delay
the development is
to use the Ability created by the
Supreme Court in response to the
legislative changes back in the
1970s to start a court process that they
cannot win that is not
not that would delay the project going
forward even though the project is
lawful under the then existing the
current
zoning and as a consequence when
developers go out to look at what
they're going to build in the first
place they're not going to look at these
small homes which often don't bring them
in a lot of profit they're going to look
at what if I look at something bigger
that has a bigger profit margin I can
build that because even if someone says
I don't like this and they delay the
process I can recoup still some profit
whereas in this case in the cases of
these types of homes you often see it's
such a small profit per home that any
delay is effectively kills the the the
you representative major thank you
Madame chair and thank you Mr Grace for
taking my question um your organization
represent present all 234 organized and
Incorporated communities within the
state of New Hampshire many of those are
not here right now because they have
other things that they have to do will
you be able to go back to the board of
directors um and say if this bill passes
that this will be a benefit to um all of
those communities that have zoning
boards uh in in in the state of New
Hampshire yes and one of the things that
we frequently see is that
municipalities
are targeted in the newspaper as the
ones at fault for delays of these types
of projects even though our boards
approved them because they were legal
ordinances representative
priest thank you Mr chairman um Madam
chair uh for taking my question and
thank you for being here um again as an
professional attorney does doesn't this
clarify the whole confusion of what and
ab butter is when they're approaching
the appeal process absolutely I think it
makes it very clear I don't think there
will be the type of confusion that we
currently
have representative
Davis thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question I'm going to
go back to my question to the sponsor
about
6723 and ask you this same question if
the bill is attempting to clarify the
language in the current
statute speed up the process for
developers hopefully encourage the
building of more affordable housing does
the definition of a butter as it
currently stands in
6723 is that at odds with what this bill
do I don't think so because it this bill
simply inserts a new sentence into the
definition it doesn't delete anything
from the definition um and that
sentence in in my in my non engineering
parlament includes those diagonal
properties that we kind of logically
assume or included as well so it doesn't
really change um that direct effect from
um one property to the other that would
that would be that standing argument
there follow up thank thank you madam
chair
so the definition in 6723 as it reads
now shall include any person who is able
to demonstrate that his land will be
directly affected by the
proposal that to me seems similarly
vague in that it it doesn't reach the
specificity that this bill proposes and
I just worry that the current definition
might
be do you see what I'm trying to get at
I I do see um certainly if there's an
amendment that you'd like to propose I'm
happy to to work with you or any member
of the committee on that to try to clear
this up so we don't have any confusion
in the
future are there any additional
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you Mr
Grace next up I have Mr David juv
from Bia and he is here to testify in
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee for the record my name
is Dave ju I'm a senior vice president
with the business and industry
Association we serve as New Hampshire's
Statewide Chamber of Commerce not before
this committee all that often um so I
want to let you know a little bit about
what Bia is we have approximately 400
employer members and they employ over a
100,000 Granite Staters so we do
uh represent uh the voice of the
business community and one of the
concerns of the business Community for
well over 10 years has been the lack of
uh housing for employees it makes it
difficult for employers to hire it makes
it difficult for employers to retain
their
Workforce you all at this point are
fairly familiar with with housing as an
issue and probably recognize that it's a
critical issue for New Hampshire it
wasn't always that way when we first
started working on housing issues around
2008 people didn't really understand why
the Bia was working on that we thought
we were working on issues relating to
subsidized housing we were not um they
thought we were working on issues to try
and change the um process by which
projects were approved uh and take away
local control we were not what we were
trying to do is educate the legislature
on the impact that housing and
especially the lack of housing has on
our economy and the ability of our
employers to hire and retain Workforce
we're supporting this bill uh because it
is not a um Silver Bullet we've learned
over the years that there is no Silver
Bullet there are a lot of issues that
impact why house sufficient housing
isn't being built to meet the needs of
this state but it does address an
important issue and I guess I want to
make sure the committee clearly
understands I think you do but I want to
make sure you clearly understand um the
reason I uh early on when I uh n told me
about the legislation I expressed a
little bit of surprise that the
municipal Association was
um the author of this bill because I'll
admit my bias I sometimes fell into that
trap of thinking that Municipal planning
boards and zoning boards were the
impediment the obstacle to housing and I
thought that this
might make housing projects easier to be
completed um the response which he
educated me on is that they work for the
uh Boards of Selectmen the planning
boards and zoning boards of all the
communities within their membership and
they felt this bill would be a benefit
and the reason why is when we're talking
about um persons
aggrieved we have to recognize if that
is being appealed what they're
appealing is a um decision by the local
planning board or zoning board after a
public hearing and after all of the uh
plans and evidence have been vetted to
allow that project to move forward they
believe it's in the best interest of the
town for that project to move
forward and yet an individual can slow
that down by uh requesting an appeal of
that decision that to me is the heart of
what this bill is trying to reduce the
um incidence of and it's why we support
it be happy to answer any
questions are there any questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you for your
testimony and thank you for allowing me
to appear afterwards appreciate
it so next I have a pin card here for Mr
Ben Frost from New Hampshire housing he
Bill thank you madam chair and good
afternoon committee members it is a uh
Delight to appear before you again
especially uh a delight because I get to
agree with the municipal Association
which is a a pleasant change of events
um attorney Gray's I think really well
outlined uh the history here uh and I
want to thank representative turkot for
introducing this important legislation
this uh Returns the posture of the law
to its a sensible place that existed in
the 1970s prior to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court's uh inexplicable decision
in weeks versus do uh where it overruled
itself um and seeks to limit uh who can
appeal uh decisions of uh or who has the
ability to appeal a decision of a zoning
Board of
adjustment um and and in so doing um
saves municipalities in addition to it
it's interesting I'm I'm going to argue
for the municipalities attorney gra was
arguing for for the affordable housing
developers which is really just it's a
fun place to
be um time is money for municipalities
too and I say this as a municipal
official the amount of time that
municipalities spend in court is costly
and to the extent you as the legislature
can reduce constrain eliminate what I
would characterize as vexatious
litigation litigation that has no merit
but its only purpose is delay
then the public is well
served um I I'm happy to take any
questions U but I think that anything
else I might say would simply be
repetitive of other Witnesses do any
members have a question for Mr
Frost seeing none thank you for your
testimony next up I have M Alysa
margolin from housing action New
Hampshire and she is also here to
Bill thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Alyssa marglin and I serve as director
of housing action New Hampshire um many
of our members are affordable housing
developers they're Mission oriented and
um in recent years they've expressed a
desire to start meeting market demand
around starter homes they have uh often
in their regions strong Partnerships
with uh municipalities and they're
essentially being asked um to to step up
in this direction uh because of the the
lack of starter homes and um so uh this
is of interest to us I I also want to
Echo my thanks to the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and chairman turot
for helping bring uh forward uh this
ambiguity in the law and as was
previously stated because it has been
vague this tactic of delay has been um a
frequent barrier to development and um
and so essentially the clarification
here and giving back the rights of
diagonal abutters uh will um we'll
clarify the law I think for all and then
um stop this kind of uh bad actor
process um our members those who are
mission oriented and essentially
nonprofits um cannot pass along the cost
of litigation to the end user so instead
they often decide not to build so with
your help we'll be able to clarify the
law um and uh and have an improved uh
policy landscape for both municipalities
and and those interested in meeting
affordable housing needs thank you I'm
happy to take any questions are there
any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony I have one final pink card
here and it's a little interesting it is
Mr Tom doosa from New Hampshire planners
Association he has um written testimony
he supports the bill but he doesn't want
room okay do we have his
testimony
okay
okay okay so that that concludes um the
hearing on House Bill 15 1359 I'm going
hearing
okay folks we're down to our last
hearing for the day uh we will will open
up the hearing on HB
1449 it's a long title I'm not going to
read it representative Hicks you are
up thank you uh chairman turot and
honorable members of the best house
committee thank you for allowing me to
introduce House Bill uh 1449 for the
record I am Matthew Hicks I represent
March 24 also known as the idilic
Village of East
conquered I will be brief because we are
running late surprisingly um House Bill
1449 seeks to clarify some ambiguity
hoping to establish continuity regarding
retroactive um property tax reappraisals
and who's responsible to investigate the
issues uh the current RSA allows the
board of tax and land appeals uh btla to
retroactively assess multiple years of
property taxes once an appeal has been
initiated likely surprise Rising
taxpayers with a significant Bill
admittedly what I know about this issue
comes from uh a constituent who brought
this to me and a conversation with a
member of the btla
recently so um I'm happy to answer
questions and promptly defer them to
Witnesses who will testify after me who
understand this issue more than I do
thank you for your testimony are there
questions for representative Hicks
representative Brown yes thank you for
taking my question uh this quickly how
often does this type of situation
occur um certainly I know that Mr
Haywood will have an answer to that
question further questions for
representative Hicks seeing none thank
testimony okay uh next we are going to
nhdra
and it looks like we're getting a twofer
is that Adam de roer
okay just turn on your mic thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee um I was involved in
several of the matters that may have
given rise to this uh particular
proposal uh on behalf of the
Dr the town of oap town excuse me sir I
I always forget to mention when you
first take the mic could you please
explain if you're for or against uh we
know up here but the rest of the
committee and Spectators do
not we're here more or less against it
it's we're here for primarily
information purposes about the the the
background of the
bill um we see it as a bit of a solution
in search of a problem and um this comes
from our experience working with the
btla and the case the cases involving
oopy Alton and Center Harbor um we were
called as Witnesses in in the Alton and
Center Harbor cases and not as assigned
tasks or hired investigators by the
board uh we have the the the Dr has a
great deal of expertise and information
that they per they perform assessment
monitoring and they look into things
that are going on in the assessment
practices in towns and they do it on a
periodic basis and they collect
information and the btla sometimes finds
that information useful and important to
consider um in the in the oopy case we
were
um the the btla used a statutory
provision which is not called into
question by this amendment to order a
reassessment of the institutionally
exempt properties in town and they did
that because they made a finding that
the quality of the tax taxing District's
program for maintenance of assessment
Equity was not adequate and so they they
felt that the town's assessor at that
time was not doing his job appropriately
and they asked the Dr essentially to do
it instead this was not a a an
investigative services performed on the
board's behalf it was a reassessment
16 the other two cases or none of these
cases actually resulted in any
significant look back in assessment or
re reevaluation of these properties um
in two of the cases the btla found that
the equities prevented them from looking
further back than one or two years where
in a couple of the cases they found that
um the towns had
allowed exemptions of properties for
many years that that those properties
were not entitled to but they found that
it was be overly burdensome or
unreasonable and inequitable to require
them to be reassessed and essentially
PID taxes for many prior years
so what I say that we see this as sort
of a kind of a a solution in search of a
problem these cases and and the history
over the last few years don't really
show that there's a need to fix this
thing um and it could at some level
interfere with the ability of the Dr to
respond to uh requests for information
and testimony and proceedings uh and
interfere with the dr's ability
Performance Mission to assure that
taxing and exemptions are done equitably
and fairly because as I'm sure you
understand every exempt property is
essentially
a slight burden on all the other
taxpayers in town so if somebody's
getting an exemption for a piece of
property that they're not entitled to
and if it's gone on for many years
that's a burden that's now been shared
by the other taxpayers in town and so
the the btas and they can speak to this
they're here um you know one of their
missions is to make sure that those kind
of things don't happen and the Dr in
some instances is called to provide
information and testimony to support
that mission
um so I I guess that's all I have to say
about it and I'll be happy to take any
questions and uh Adam denore is the
assistant director of the municipal and
property Division and he's been around
for most of this U work as well and he's
I'm sure he'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you for your testimony
representative
power thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question so there's two
parts to this bill and I'm um curious
about the second part
that um speaks to the Investigative
Services done by the Dr so the bill says
the board which is the
btla shall not rely on the Dr to provide
Investigative Services do you read this
to mean
that the Dr could still provide
Investigative Services and some I'm a
little confused by that and could you
help clarify thank you for that question
I don't know if I can help clarify that
because I'm confused by it as well um
we've never been asked by the btla to
provide Investigative Services on the
board's behalf at least not in my
experience since
2017 um it's my understanding and the
the folks from the board can speak to
this they have their own investigators
to do this work or they can get
them for the questions representative
Brown thank you Mr chairman so this is
kind of the question I asked Mr Hicks
representative Hicks so how many of
these and how far back could you go to
do this search thank you thank you for
your question as I said in in the five
years or six years that I've been
working for the Dr this this kind of
issue has come up in essentially two
cases Alton and Center Harbor and in
both of those cases is while there was
evidence that the both of those towns
had extensive record of not doing the
exemptions properly that is granting
exemptions to property owners who are
not entitled to them the board declined
to
um do reassessments for all of those
past years because they found it to be
inequitable sure go ahead you also
mentioned oopy could you touch on that
too thank you so oopy was came to our
came to the board's attention and the
dr's attention when a taxpayer
complained to the btla and to the Dr
that the town had improperly granted an
exemption to an organization in this in
believe in one or two years um there was
a long process involving the town's
assess
and the town and the board that
developed over a couple of years that
left the board feeling a lack of
confidence in the Assessor's
capabilities and work and responses to
the board's questions and inquiries and
requests for information and and as a
result of that the um board ordered the
Dr to perform a reassessment of those
properties which we did and completed
just what two weeks
ago and that involves something like 17
properties and only for the years 22 and
23 thank you for
questions seeing none I have a quick
question for you um these cases that
you're talking about do you have a
document that would that
summarizes uh like say what happened in
Alton what happened
sen Harbor is it like a it's not a court
case I know but do you have a
summarizing document on any of those
there thank you for your question and I
I I do not have a document like that
with me um the board has prepared a
series of orders that could be provided
although that would require this
committee to sort of analyze them and
look at them um I could inquire of the
commissioner to see if I if we could
provide something that's some summarizes
those cases at least from the dr's
perspective for myself I I would love if
you could do that on say a couple of
them or even just one of them just so I
can get an idea of what you're doing I
I'm not sure how many want to see it but
uh when you get it if you could send it
to me that'd be great certainly I I'll
I'll I'll ask the commissioner I don't
have the authority to offer that but I'm
sure I I could probably persuade her to
do it okay thank you further
questions see none thank you for your
testimony morning thank you uh next up
we
btla good
afternoon um yes it is another twer um I
am Teresa Walker I'm a member of the
board of tax and land appeals um I was
appointed to the board in
2012 um with me is an stac she's the
board's Clerk and has been the board's
clerk for over 25 years and behind us is
Michelle Le BR who is the the board's
chair so um we did provide some written
testimony um we sent it through the the
kiosk the website so hopefully uh the
committee members have had an
opportunity to at least receive it I
know it came today so you probably
haven't had an opportunity to digest it
um but I'll I'll begin my testimony by
saying that as written the board cannot
support this piece of
legislation um and there's a number of
reasons why um as drafted we find the
language to be very ambiguous and rather
than
clarifying any of the statutes that the
board works with it's providing
additional levels of gray area I would
say um
specifically um the phrase outside the
years in question gen um the words
themselves are easy to understand but
when you apply those words to the
various statutes that the board has
jurisdiction to hear appeals from that
becomes very murky most property tax
appeals specifically are retroactive in
nature uh Municipal reassessments are
prospective in nature so is the statute
talking about the current calendar year
the current tax year
um a certain number of tax years before
and after the date that we hear the case
it's it's not clear um the second reason
that we can't support it is it is intend
the bill is drafted to amend um chapter
71b which is a very general statute it's
the board's enabling
statute if this issue has
aisen regarding um some prior rulings
that the board has made in institutional
exemption cases perhaps a clarification
of a date would be appropriate in
chapter 72 which pertains specifically
to those exemption properties that we
heard a little bit about um but the
general statute of 71b would apply to
all cases that come before the board
including current use
including
um uh excavation including all state
taxes rooms and meals and so forth
um regarding the second part of this in
the investigative services on behalf of
the board I E I will just say ditto to
what uh attorney Ro testified to we have
the board has not in its history asked
the Department of Revenue to provide any
sort of Investigative Services the board
has asked um that the Dr
provide copies of any investigations
they may have done under their separate
jurisdiction
um in one specific statute that comes to
mind in terms of Timber tax um the board
has the specific authority to request
the Department of Revenue provide
experts testimony uh they on their staff
have some subject matter experts in the
area of Timber which the board does not
have so in those cases we have called
upon them to provide that testimony but
in no in no shape or form have we
ordered or requested the Dr um do any
sort of Investigation on the board's
behalf
um with that
um the we've heard testimony very kind
of vague testimony regarding
oapi Alton and Center Harbor all three
of those uh cases uh came to the board
um two of them as a result of taxpayer
complaints and one of those arose from
the testimony in the oapi case
um all of those cases had to do with the
granting of charitable
exemptions um actually I take that back
OAB had to do with charitable and
religious
I don't think educational and the other
two were about charitable um in the town
of oapi which is the first case um the
board did order the taxpayer who had
improperly been granted the uh
charitable exemption to repay the town a
total of three years um the board
asserted its Authority um that has been
given to it in
71b and in several uh Supreme Court
cases is most notably of which is the
appeal of woodlow um which I do have a
copy of here I'm happy to share that
with the committee
um the the statute is not clear on how
board was faced with having to as was
testified to by attorney Ro trying to
balance the I ities
of
the the financial burden this may place
on the specific
taxpayer as well as the
disproportionality that the granting of
the exemption caused to all other
taxpayers within the
community given everything in the record
the board found that ordering those
three years which took the taxpayer or
the the payments back to
the town's last Municipal wide re
assessment to be
reasonable
um they had received that exemption for
many years more than
that
um in
Meredith and in Alton the board took a
similar stance Center Harbor I'm sorry
what did I say again I said that earlier
today too in both other cases the board
um found in a very similar fashion we
ordered repayments back to the date of
the last
revaluation um in Alton I believe that
was 2
years and
in Center
Harbor it actually ended up being no
years because they had revaled just
board
does not have to deal with these
issues on a regular
basis these three cases clustered close
together was very
unusual
um and actually our clerk has data to to
show how many cases and what the
disposition of those cases were yes I
can answer your question representative
Brown because I am a statistics person
and I I have been there for over 20
years and I was surprised um I thought
we had actually more but we have um a
total of
15 including the three that were most
recent three of those dealt with
exemptions but the other 12 were all
you'll be shocked neighbor versus
neighbor because nothing makes a great
case like when your neighbor doesn't
like what you're doing on your property
and you're he thinks you're getting away
with something so the 12 were neighbor
versus neighbor and a complaint so three
of them were exemptions um there were
eight times where again there was a
couple of neighbors or um just the board
on their own figured out by way of
another case that uh we should look into
this there's something
wrong eight cases and they never
asserted jurisdiction but all they did
was send out an order saying hey what's
going on here tell us what's happening
are we seeing this wrong or is this
person wrong
and they never ended up asserting their
jurisdiction so when you look at it 15
times three were exemptions which are
embedded in chapter
2072 and the rest were under chapter
76 um and there is no time limit that is
absolutely for certain but in the case
of Center Harbor and and this is what I
will say about it I'm happy to provide
you an oopy order I actually came armed
with enough copies of one oopy of one
oopy order that I think encapsulates
it's not a summary but it will give you
the most detail um but in Center Harbor
that particular charitable or was
religious excuse me religious entity
escaped taxation for 17 years and had
they collected the money the town of
Center Harbor and those taxpayers would
have benefited from $2
million so I sat in a My Town
deliberative session this weekend and I
tell you the longest eight and a half
hours of my life listening to people
upset about my taxes my taxes we went
through a reval the tax rates through
the roof well $2 million in a town like
Center Harbor you know so that's the
that's the piece but for the rest of
these people um exemptions weren't the
case that is that's the norm um out of
all the appeals we get a year and the
average is you know anywhere right now
we're roughly we have you know 700 cases
open a year with about 400 new filed um
going back the earliest I could find was
1995 and that's where I'm getting this
data from from
1995 um so if that's
helpful as U Miss stach mentioned we do
have a copy of the order in op that the
board wrote um and it's the order that
the in which the board ordered the
Department of Revenue Administration to
actually perform the reassessment of the
institutional exempt properties in O and
we're happy to provide that to the
members of the committee if you'd like
that thank Youk you very much
representative
yella thank you uh thank you for taking
um it seems from your testimony that the
statute is
unclear
um about how long you
can do these these assess uh
reassessments or re-evaluations or or
assess penalties and
maybe in and the essentially the the
legislature has given you that
flexibility to let's say if in the case
uh if a case came before you that you
felt that there was fraud or something
like that that you may say like okay
you're going back all the way to the end
of time because you did something wrong
and you knew it versus oh it was an
honest mistake or something like that
and maybe you could be more lenient and
um is that the case or are you kind of
setting a precedent that no every single
time we're just going to go back to a v
uh the last EV
vow um I can't sit here well first of
all none of the orders in any of those
three cases made a blanket statement
that this is what the board will always
find the the decisions are always very
fact specific to the case
um but I think some of the issues that
you raised may be those things that the
board would take into consideration
before making a
decision um the it isn't that the
statute isn't clear on what the timeline
is it's 100% silent on the issue okay so
the board gleans its Authority from case
law has written that um and again it's
the a case of wood flower that I have
and we can distribute and I see Miss
delmock looking at another case so I
will let her go with
that yeah this just goes to put this in
reference I found a case Hill versus
Martin 1954 great year and this court
does the Supreme Court said since the
legislature imposed no time limit within
which a reassessment should be made it
must be deemed to have anticipated the
inevitable results of a late
correction so
1954 they didn't know it
then representative Brown thank you Mr
chairman so just a quick followup I'm
trying to make sure I understood it
correctly so on the center Harbor case
which had to do with a religious
exemption right you found that it wasn't
the exemption wasn't proper and that you
went back to the last assessment and
even though you found that they were due
$2 million there was no additional
assessment that is that is correct thank
you further questions
seeing none thank you ladies for your
testimony thank you very much I have one
Haywood sure I don't forget to turn that
on welcome thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee my name is Todd Haywood
uh I live in conquered New Hampshire
representative Hicks is my
representative I've uh I've been a
member of the the assessment assessing
Community for 24 years now um I am a
consultant for 11 towns so I provide
assessment advice to the statutory
assessors who are the selectman or uh if
there is one Board of assessors so as
you can imagine you can give advice
doesn't mean that they're always going
to take your advice which is fine U what
what I see what I would like to focus on
with this
is is maybe is Maybe improving the
system so that there's a little bit more
continuity among different forms of
government for example under the current
system if I'm a taxpayer and I live in
conquered I pay taxes in conquered and
Miss stac mentioned neighbor on neighbor
but let's just say that my I noticed my
neighbor is under assessed well I have
90 days to appeal that assessment after
the final notice
attacks whereas if I were a municipality
the Supreme Court had said in the late
90s in uh the Pheasant Lane realy case
where they said if you've I'm
paraphrasing and I'm not an attorney but
if you've issued a tax and in this case
there was the the fee Lane mall and the
city discovered that they were grossly
under assessing this property in their
opinion based on the income they they
had estimated income then they gathered
information that found the actual income
was twice that so they figured it was it
was probably in the best interest of the
rest of the taxpayers to not let this
taxpayer go under assess so the issued a
supplemental tax bill well the Supreme
Court said once the tax has been issued
you can't you can't add to it for your
municipality then again not long after
that in in LSP Association versus
Guilford belnap County Judge determined
that that particular property was under
assessed and added a tax based on that
of the hearing or the proceeding that
day Supreme Court also said can't add a
tax you can only Abate so the so what
I'm the point I think is this not
necessarily a problem looking for a
solution but maybe to bring things more
in line it's you know 90 days that tax
year tax year under appeal forever you
could maybe bring up the taxpayer's
ability to to appeal for a year or two
or five or whatever same thing with the
superior court so the the question is is
more an issue for me of of of continuity
and and how you how you might address
that and and and like that's that in in
all the other testimony I I don't have
any difference of agreement because your
questions I think have been answered so
far but I'd be happy to answer any
further
questions thank you thank you for the
testimony
questions representative
yella thank you thank you for taking the
that for these different appeals the 90
days your neighbor so the examples they
gave was neighbor on neighbor um you're
saying in
certain situations they can only appeal
but to whom I guess is the question
because if it was to the board it seems
to be forever and so
the who has the 90-day
requirement um versus the municipality
could the municipality code to the board
and get the forever uh date in in the in
that case all of them would be the same
they could all just go to the board so
thank you for your question not an
attorney but I believe that would be 71
B16 that says if there if you discover
there's an erroneous or illegal
assessment you have 90 days from the
date of the final notice of tax as far
as the municipalities
go I'd have to defer I'm not sure how
that would work I don't know of any case
where they they can go to the board for
someone for something that they
essentially did or didn't
do in that in a case like
that represent
power thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um my question is on
line seven I see you don't have the bill
but I guess I'll read it it says but the
board shall not order retroactive
reappraisals outside of and this is what
I need clarification on the years in
question is that on some application is
it on some kind of a complaint H how is
the years in question determined and by
whom thank you well the when you appeal
to the board you you have to cite which
year you're appealing so for example in
the in the case where if I were
appealing my neighbors I would say I
have 90 days from the 2023 tax bill
issue so I would be appealing the 20
2023 taxes within 90 days of that date
if I were appealing my taxes I would
have to cite the year in question and so
vtla and they they may be able to expand
on this more but they have you know
their their dockets are the year of
appeal and then there's docket number so
that's it's it's
helps further
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony right thank you I do not have
any more pink cards if anybody else was
here to testify I don't have it seeing
none I will go ahead and we will close
now just an email
oh actually for everybody who's here yep
um next week
on Tuesday um if you'll notice in the
the very beginning of the schedule
there's 9:30 there's an
exec just so everybody knows what that
is that was representative y's bill that
was sent over and incorporated into a
Senate bill which has
already uh a house no you said the
Senate Bill did I say Senate I did not
mean that you're right in the judici
house Judiciary correct all right um
representative Lynn uh chairman Lynn
added that to a bill that's already been
taken care of so we're simply going to
come
in and itl it because it's a it's a it's
a uh early bill so we have to get it off
the books I was just going to hold it
but we got to get it off so that's all
it's going to be it's going to be a
motion to itl and we're going to get rid
of it then we'll get into our regular
hearings is that okay representative
yella I mean since since the bill got
passed and fine yeah I would think so
okay very good we'll see everybody next
tomorrow
that